learn how to create your very own
programming language and the only
prerequisite knowledge is basic python
Ariane Hegde teaches this course along
the way you'll learn more about object
oriented programming linear data
structures binary trees recursion
tokenization parsing and more so let's
get started welcome to this brand new
course where I'll be teaching you how
you can create your own programming
language using python now the goal of
this project was to teach you how you
can Implement a bunch of programming
Concepts into a real world project I
have always felt that especially in
computer science Concepts have been
taught in a sort of abstract and
detached manner independent from The
Real World and that's why in this course
I bring to you a bunch of Concepts like
data structures like algorithms
recursion object oriented programming I
teach how you can Implement all of these
Concepts into a real world project you
can also head over to
blog.algalon.net or click on the link in
the description where I talk about a
bunch of learning methods I employ
during my learning phase to have a
better grasp on Concepts and a higher
memory retention now the only
prerequisite for this course is basic
python knowledge stuff like if
statements variables while loops and
functions and with the basic foundations
laid I'll take you to the next level
talking about data structures algorithms
recursion and much more and by the end
of this course you'll have your own
programming language so by the end of
this project we'll be having the final
output so this is our I've run the
shell.py file over here and this is what
our output is going to look like so
we're going to input our shadow script
code
as a python input so I'm gonna say let's
say we can give an input arithmetic
expression so one plus one it returns
two I can do 5 plus 3 it will give us 8.
now I can even talk about order of
operation so I can even do one plus four
multiplied by 7.
in the wrong order of operations that'll
be 5 times 7 which is 35 but the correct
way to load is multiplication first so
we'll have 7 times 4 which is 28 plus
129 which is what we get
if we want to make the addition we want
to give higher priority tradition we can
add a pair of parentheses
multiply by 7 and this should give us
35. so that's all about arithmetic
Expressions that we can give it apart
from math it can do other stuff as well
it can create variables so I'm going to
say make
variable a
and I can assign that variable to the
value 10 and like how in JavaScript you
have the VAR declaration or the let
declaration and this time we're using
make so the make will be used to create
a new variable so we create a variable
called a and give it give it the value
10. I can make another variable B set it
to 15. and I can make another variable C
and set it to a plus b
and this stores the correspond the
variables and the corresponding values
in a python dictionary now after
variables we can also deal with
conditional operators and comparison
operators so sorry Boolean operators and
comparison operators
so Boolean operators is something like
stuff like and or and not the comparison
operators are greater than less than is
one thing equal to another thing and so
on so I can run a Boolean operation I
can say 7 greater than 2 and
5 greater than 3 in this case both of
the
um expression 7 greater than 2 and 5
greater than three both are true and
therefore this should return 1 which
stands for true if I do 7 greater than 2
and 5 Less Than 3 which will return 0
which stands for false act into 7
greater than 2 or 5 Less Than 3 which
will give me 1 again
I can do not so I can say not 7 greater
than 2 so this will give me 0 because 7
is greater than 2 and then we're not in
that operation we are inverting it where
um turning 1 to 0.
so that's the Boolean operators we can
even have two two things are the same I
can check if C is equal to B so this is
how I use it in Python you have two
equal symbols to check if one variable
is equal to another in in our syntax we
Define it as C question mark equals B
and if I run this this is 0 y because 25
is not equal to 15.
I can make another variable d
set it to 25
and now if I do D equals to C this will
give us 1. so that's the comparison
operators I can't even check if C is
greater than a and that gives us 1 and
so on
so apart from the comparison operators
you can now use if statements so I can
say
if
a is greater than 3
do something so do
three times three that makes no sense
but let's just see if this works and
that will give us the output 9 because a
is greater than 3 but if I do if a is
less than 3 do 3 times 3 it will give me
nothing
I can answer on ellips so I can know if
a is less than 3 do 3 times 3 l if a is
greater than 12 do 5 times 5
else do 10 times 6 so in this case a is
not greater than 3 and it is not greater
than 12. so both the conditions won't be
met and it will go to the else statement
and run 10 times 6 which is 60 as the
output
now the final thing that we Implement in
this course is while Loops as well so
how do you run a while loop I can say
while
a is less than 15. do and then we have
to make a statement so do
following a statement with following the
do keyword we have to give a statement
like make a equals a plus one so
incrementing is value by 1.
and this will print the variables list
in every iteration of the loop
so that's all there is to it in this
course we haven't talked about more
advanced functionalities like strings or
possibly even
styles of programming which we could
Implement in our language like object
oriented programming or functional
programming we haven't talked about
those aspects because we want to keep
this course simple while also
learning about a lot of other computer
science Concepts like data structures
algorithms and the programming paradigms
and lots of stuff so we're gonna talk
about all of those Concepts from a
beginner level and by the end of this
course we'll have this amazing project
built from scratch so let's begin this
course
so I'm going to start this course by
talking about how computers are able to
read code on a high level now this is
not really necessary to understand the
implementation phase of this course
where we will be dealing with python
code and writing our interpreter but I
just think that this help would helps
put things into perspective and explains
how computers are able to actually do
this stuff in a more physical manner
so ultimately
um if you've scaled the microscopic
level you'll find that computers are
made of transistors and they are
indicated by the following symbol
so um the two wires over here are
electrodes
and in between is a material known as a
semiconductor
a semiconductor typically made of
silicon or I'm not really going to go
into the chemistry but but it composes
of silicon and semiconductor is a
material that allows current to flow
through given a certain input from the
control wire so this is the control wire
when the control wire is on the
semiconductor will allow current to flow
through it when the control wire is off
the semiconductor won't allow current
refer to it so let's represent
um these states on and off using two
numbers zero and one also known as
binary so
when the control wire is on the
semiconductor conducts electricity and
if this let's say is the output
so then and let's consider the control
wire as the input so we have input and
output and we have a way to represent
data using binary
so over here
input is 1 the control wire is on the
semiconductor can conduct electricity
and it will generate the output 1 and if
it is off the output will also be off
Now using transistors we can generate
logic gates there are multiple ways to
generate logic gates
um you can use different mechanisms as
well but typically inside a computer
you'll find transistors and transistors
forming the logic gates
so how do you make a transition how do
you make a logic gate from a transistor
I'm going to start off with a simple
logic gate which is known as the not
gate in fact there are three of them
there's the not
the and and the or
which are the fundamental logic gates
that computers use they are also known
as Boolean operators that we will be
working with during this course during
the implementation so not essentially
reverses the input so if the input is
one a not operation turns it to zero the
input is zero the not operation turns it
to one
and this not gate is built from
transistors one way you can build a not
gate is
okay let me draw that again
you can have the output go in that way
and have the control y over here so
control bar is the input and that's the
output so over here
input and output
if the input is 1 that means current
will flow in this direction it will go
down and flow in this direction so the
output will be zero if the input is zero
the output will be 1. and what I'm
drawing over here these tables so
I know why that's not working yeah there
we go so these tables are also known as
truth tables they're one of the first
things you actually taught in computer
science anyway so it's it's just like
four cells in an Excel sheet anyway
so that's what the not gate does
similarly you can construct the and and
the nor gate using just combination of
transistors I'm not going to go into
those details but all you need to know
is that the not gate flips the input
operation the or gate has a different
sort of truth table for a certain input
it has two inputs i1 and let's say I2
and one output if both of them are on
this will be on if one is on it'll still
be on but if both of them are off the
output will be off
so that's the or gate the and gate is
um another logical logical operator it
has two inputs i1 and I2
and it has an output and only if both i1
and I2 are on will the output be on
otherwise the output will be zero
so that's the basics of you know and
Gates not Gates and or Gates these form
the fundamental logic gates there are
some other Gates as well like the X
socket but I'm not going to talk about
them right now these Gates instead of
representing them as transistors we
represent them as their own symbol so
let me just draw their own symbol
and that's the or gate
3 Gates three simple
so how do computers perform arithmetic
with these logic gates there are two
main functionalities we're looking for
arithmetic and memory and once we
understand both of them I'm gonna move
on to the more
um the side of this course which is more
relevant to creating your own
programming language so again as I said
we have two operations to accomplish
arithmetic which is basic algebra or uh
not basic algebra basic addition
subtraction multiplication or Division
and the memory is refers to storing data
essentially storing binary and then we
can use the binary to represent other
forms of data like for instance video or
audio or whatever
so anyway
before we move on to the arithmetic I
want to talk about another gate which is
the Excel gate I'm now going to talk
about how it's formed this is its symbol
it's similarly or gate actually and
that's you know
yeah there we go
so that's how the xorbit looks like and
it looks similar to the or gate it too
has two inputs I2 and i1
and the truth table
and the truth table is something like
this if both are 0 the output is zero if
either one of them is on the output is
on
or one and if both of them are 1 the
output is zero
that's the xor gate
now in binary you can also perform
addition so what I was referring to as
arithmetic let's say you want to add the
binary numbers one and one
so you would have to represent them as 1
0 essentially uh how do you how you
represent binary numbers is the
following you you represent decimal
numbers which is the base 10 notation in
forms of in the form of powers of 10 so
for instance 10 to the power 0 10 to the
power 1 10 to the power 2 and so on so
that's the ones position tens and
hundreds position and so on that we've
been learning in elementary school so if
you have let's say uh the number
3 4 6 so that just corresponds to 3
times 10 to the power 0 plus 4 times 10
to the power 1 plus 6 times 10 to power
2 which is 643.
so that's how we represent
um decimal numbers but binary is
different it is base 2 so you have 2 to
the power 0 2 to the power 1 and 2
squared
and you can't have numbers from 0 to 9
it's not base 10 you have you can have
numbers only from 0 and 1 so 0 and 1. so
if you want to represent the number
three let's say so that'll be 0 over
here
one over here a little bit it'll be one
over here
1 over here and 0 over here so 0 1 1 is
3 how so
um let's do that so it's 1 times 10 to
the power 0 plus 1 times 10 to the power
1 plus 0 times 2 to the power 2 and this
turns out to be 3.
so that's how you do uh basic addition
in in binary
so
so that's how you do basic addition in
binary now if you look at the xor gate
the truth table of the xor gate it
actually looks pretty similar to our
Edition so I'm gonna do addition for uh
one bit numbers only just to demonstrate
the idea of arithmetic using logic gates
so I'm gonna do 0 plus 0 which is zero
zero plus one which is zero
one plus zero which is one
okay and the previous one is also one
and one plus one as I said it's not
going to be
um
two it's going to be one zero and one
zero essentially refers to the fact that
it's two to the power zero and two to
the power one so you have a 0 over here
and one over here so that's just 2 to
the power 1 times 1 which is two and one
zero equals 2 in decimal
so now if you look at this over here you
can see that the sum which is the first
number
is exactly the same as the xor gate it's
0 1 1 0 0 1 1 0. but the carry bit which
is this one over here that's called the
carry bit because it becomes like like
in decimal Edition you take one as the
carry so you take one over here and then
that comes down over here as one so
on the carry bit is one that we have to
we have to find another gate for the
carry bit the carry bit is zero in these
cases but one over here and that's the
situation for the and gate so if you can
combine the or gate the xor gate and the
and gate you can actually come up with a
way to handle addition in
um using logic gates only and that's
essentially how we go that's the
starting point you go from there uh try
to handle more complicated arithmetic
like multiplication or Division and it's
the that's the same basic idea you are
trying to hook up logic gates in a smart
manner to perform calculations and
that's how arithmetic Works in computers
so now let's talk about memory I'll be
using a component called the and or
latch as an example to show how
computers have the ability to store data
so it's called the and on latch as I
said so let me just construct it
so R stands for reset s stands for set
and O is the output so we use the set
um wire
to save data so if you want to say save
the num save the binary number one or
just want to save the bit one so how do
we do that so the first thing we need to
do is turn on the set wire so I'm going
to draw a truth table over here
so we have set reset
and let's not worry about reset for now
and output
so if you put set as 1 and reset as 0
what will happen to the output so this
is an odd this is an or gate over here
so
on or gate so once once you turn on the
set wire
one gets transmitted over here because
if either of the inputs of the or gate
are 1 the output of the or gate is one
so the output of the or gate is one over
here and the reset is zero so zero gets
knotted and that becomes one so now the
and gate
converts these two input ones into the
output one so in the following scenario
where in where you turn on the set wire
and leave this reset wire as it is the
output turns out to be one
now afterwards
if we turn off the set y let's turn off
the set wire so let's make it zero and
there is the reset wire is still zero
what will happen to the output
so now the set wire is zero but
regardless since the output is one and
that was fed back as an input to the or
gate this is one over here and since one
of the inputs is one to the auger this
Still Remains as one this uh uh the
input to the and gate the right the
bottom input to the and gate Still
Remains is one and therefore the output
Still Remains as one so the output is
effectively unchanged
even after we uh stopped even after we
turned off the set wire and that is
effectively what computer memory looks
like so the computer has remembered
the state
it was in and that is known as saving or
computer memory you can delete it by
turning on the reset key and that's also
pretty easy to follow if we turn on the
ezt that gets knotted to zero and one of
the inputs of the and Gates becomes 0
and the output becomes zero and we are
back to our original state so that's how
basically computers store memory it's
solve this feedback mechanism that they
use that helps them store memory and now
that we've understood these two concepts
let's go ahead to the next section where
we will talk about the need for
programming and why we need to use
programming languages
so what is the need for programming
that's what we're going to talk about in
this section of the course now
programming refers to giving input
instructions to come to a computer so
that we can execute them so before we
understand how programming works we have
to understand how computers understand
instructions
that's a mouthful let me say that again
to understand how programming works we
need to understand how computers
interpret instructions and as I said all
all along that they do this using logic
gates so we have a set of logic gates
hooked up in a smart way so that they
can detect certain instructions like for
instance if we have the instruction one
zero zero zero
so that's the 4-bit instruction over
here now how do we decode this the
computer has a control unit which is
responsible for checking for certain
instructions looking for certain
instructions and once it finds those
instructions it will perform the
necessary action so
that's how computers interpret
instructions they have a control unit
control units composed of logic gates so
let me just say you have the instruction
like this so this is the instruction
it's fed into control unit
and the control unit
um detects the instruction checks if uh
say for instance the instruction one
zero zero corresponds to uh adding and
adding to memory let's say
so the control unit will check for that
instruction if the instruction is one
zero zero and again these instructions
are stored in the memory of the of the
computer we talked about how computers
uh save Things So the instructions are
stored in the memory of the computer so
um once it once it so it sequentially
goes through all of the instructions
stored in the memory and let's say this
is the instruction at first encounters
and it tries to match it with the
instruction one zero zero zero and let's
say in this situation where it does
match with this number
uh
this number let's say the instruction is
one triple zero in that case the control
unit will detect it using a logic gates
and once it has detected that
instruction it will go ahead and perform
the operation of saving to memory
so this two stages detecting the
instruction using the control unit and
then performing the uh instruction so
you have a table like currents
corresponding to 1000 uh corresponds to
saving to memory maybe zero one zero
zero corresponds to doing arithmetic
adding two numbers let's say
so you have a table of these
instructions so you first design these
instructions and then computers
programmers will go ahead and input
these instructions into the computer's
memory the computer would sequentially
perform each instruction and will
execute them so this is how Computing
works on a really high level and the
problem arose and this is in the early
ages of computing the problem arose was
that the problem which arose was that
you used harder mediums which is like
Hardware interactions to input data
these instructions like one zero zero uh
were fed in by mechanisms like switches
or plug boards or um you had some Punch
Cards so these harder mechanisms are not
really effective especially if you have
thousands of instructions to give to the
computer
and that resulted in the need for a
softer way a softer medium for
interacting with a computer and that
gave birth to a compiler a compiler
converts you have high source code high
level source code which is essentially a
programming language like Python and
that source code is written in such a
way that it's human readable and you
have a compiler which is just another
computer
which uses a set of techniques to
convert that source code into binary
which is also known as a machine code
so that's the job of a compiler can
converts source code into machine code
and in this entire course we'll be
learning about a lot of processes that
compilers use to convert to machine code
namely lexical analysis and um passing
and interpretation we won't be building
a compiler we'll be building an
interpreter so we won't be dealing with
converting the instructions into binary
outputs rather we'll be using a
programming language like python to
convert to to interpret data in sequence
to input interpret our own programming
language sequentially so a compiler
converts to machine code but our
interpreter won't be doing that it will
be using a programming language like
python to understand our given input and
then process it and perform the
necessary action so anyway that's it for
this section we've talked about how
computers understand
instructions how they execute those
instructions
and the need for compilers to convert
high level code to low level code and
those low level codes is just binary
instructions and now with that
information it's time to move ahead to
the next section where we will be
delving more into the implementation
side of this course so I'll see you over
there
in our interpretation process there are
three steps involved the first step is
known as lexical analysis
and then after that you go ahead and do
parsing
and the final stage is the
interpretation
which is done by The Interpreter
so three steps and if you encapsulate
these three steps into its own box
so I have an interpreter over here and
that box is called an interpreter
and if I input some code which is in our
own in our custom programming language
and for the purposes of this course this
programming language will be called
Shadow script which is a fancy name for
a not so capable language
um because of course we won't be able to
achieve
tasks that advance programming languages
like python or JavaScript can do but
nonetheless we'll be talking about the
core functionalities like variables like
arithmetic operations
um uh some if statements while loops and
possibly even for Loops so all of that
code will be implemented it won't be as
powerful as the modern programming
languages but still it's a great great
opportunity to learn lots of programming
Concepts so anyway this interpreter will
take high level code and in our in our
programming language it will take Shadow
script in it
so it will ingest Shadow script and spit
out
um the necessary actions the necessary
output like say for instance you're
creating variables it will spit out the
value of the variable and save the
variable if you want to do some
arithmetic operations it will it will do
the arithmetic for you and spit out the
output and so on so they'll just give an
output
and it may also deal with some of the
memory processes like saving new
variables deleting variables and all of
that so it produces an output which will
be visible on the shell
uh on on the terminal and it will also
be dealing with some memory changes
so it's these three steps that um
okay I don't know what happened over
here let's just fix that
so it's these three steps that we have
to talk about because this is this is
what goes on inside the black spot black
box and the first step is lexical
analysis so I'm going to create a new
page for this one
and this is known as lexical analysis
the process is pretty straightforward
easier than the other steps and it
involves just breaking down the input
code into specific tokens now the tokens
for our purposes can have a value and
also a type like for instance the number
five has a value of five
and So that's its value and a type of
integer
the plus operator
has a value of Plus
and it's a type of operator so oh
so the lexical analysis just breaks down
the tokens breaks down the input into
tokens and that's pretty much it that's
all it does and in the next stage we'll
feed the tokens as an input to the
parsing so the input of the lexical
analysis is the original code the output
produced from lexical analysis will go
to the parser and the output of the
parser will go to The Interpreter and
The Interpreter will give the final
output so
lexical analysis you give an input and
I'm going to call it tokenization
because lexical analysis is pretty hard
to say
and they mean the same thing so yeah so
tokenization you give an input which is
the shadow script code
so tokenization
and
it will break down the input code into
specific tokens
and in our case it will store those
tokens in in a python list I'll talk
about data structures in just a few
moments but probably in the next few
sections but
just know that it will store the tokens
in a sequential way in a list so list is
just like a traditional list
token one
token 2 and so on
so that's a list and this is the first
item of the list this is the second item
of the list and that's how a python
python list looks like
now to give an example let's say the
input is the arithmetic operation one
plus three
so we want to add the numbers one and
three so after the tokenization process
the output should look something like
this
it should store the token value
of 1 and of type integer
then it should store the token okay
let's
put it below
so first we'll store token
one
and it will be a type integer
then it will store a token
the plus symbol or add symbol and that's
an operator
and so on
and the third final one is the third
token which represents the integer three
so that's the output of the lexical
analysis stage and now let's go to the
next section where we will talk about
how we process these tokens this stream
of tokens how we process them
so the next step is called parsing so
from the tokenization process we have
received a bunch of tokens stored in a
python list and now we have to process
that that list and generate a useful
output
so what is parsing first of all let's
understand the definition of parsing and
fundamentally parsing is just the
recognition of patterns in an input
like say for instance we have the input
one plus one
and in a very simplistic uh interpreter
for our programming language
we can we can
interpret this expression by first
tokenizing it so we tokenize this
into a bunch of tokens we have the
number one and we have the plus symbol
and then we have the number one again
and now once we have these tokens in the
list in the parsing process we look for
a pattern in a simplistic way let's say
The Interpreter can process only the
addition or subtraction of two singular
digit numbers like for instance one plus
one or three plus four or five plus six
or something like that
in this case the pattern that the parser
has to recognize is that the first
number is an integer
the first okay wrong
the pattern that The Interpreter has to
recognize is the first number is an
integer or the first token is an integer
the second token is an operator and the
operator could be plus or minus
and the third token is again another
integer
that's all that the parser has to
recognize and the simplistic scenario
there's an integer plus or minus another
integer and the parser just the remember
the lexical analysis of the tokenization
process blindly converts the input into
a bunch of tokens it does not look at
any structure it does not see if the
input abides by the programming language
rules it doesn't do anything like that
all it does is converts the input into a
bunch of tokens but in the parser it
tries to search for patterns it tries to
search for this pattern of integer
integer plus integer
so that's the general pattern so integer
plus or minus and this vertical bar is
also known as r
so plus or minus another integer
so that's the pattern that we're trying
to look for in the simplistic scenario
of course this is not how our parsing
process will be in the in the
implementation side we will be able to
deal with extremely complicated
Expressions as well
but this is just to give an example of
what parsing really is all it is is
trying to find structure and
um essentially it goes a step further
from the lexical analysis and tries to
structurize the input
how does it do that and it does this
using a bunch of grammar rules now in
this simple scenario the only grammar
rule grammar rule is that an expression
is an integer
plus or minus another integer
in fact I'll write this in a better way
so
so it's an integer plus an integer
integer minus an integer
and the vertical bar here so either this
is one possibility or this is the other
possibility
so in this simple grammar Rule and this
is the this layout is known as a grammar
rule there are certain formats of
writing a grammar Rule and I'll come to
that in just a second but this grammar
rule essentially defines the structure
of a programming language
the parser
checks for certain patterns check for
such checks for such structures and C's
if the input matches for them if it does
not match them then there's probably an
error in the input core and an error
must be raised
so let's talk about let's now talk about
the types of grammar rules that exist
so the ways in which you can write
grammar rules the the one I'm going to
use is called P and F and that's
extremely hard to pronounce but it's
called Backus nor form I believe and I
probably misspelled mispronounce that
but anyway B and F is a way of writing
your grammar rules and let's just go
through a bunch of examples now
in basic math we have let's say an
expression an expression just contains a
bunch of terms and a term is just a
bunch of integers multiplied together
so what does that mean so let me let me
go through this again I'm going to say
an expression
is equal to an in Bacchus now form you
actually have two colons over here
like that but I'm just going to write it
as one colon because it looks much more
prettier
so like that expression is equal to
a term
plus another expression
or it's equal to a term
minus another expression
or it's equal to just a term
now this may seem a bit confusing
because we're calling the expression
inside the expression but what this
tries to do is just ensure that there is
a form of continuity in our expression
what does that mean so let's say we have
the expression 5 plus 3 plus 2. now
that's an expression It's a combination
of terms and a term can be an integer or
it can also be two integers multiplied
or divided but I'll come to that in just
a second for now let's just assume a
term is an integer
so an expression just contains a bunch
of integers added or subtracted together
now this is where my recursion comes
into play and I'll talk about recursion
in probably the probably the next few
sections but essentially recursion is a
way is a type of programming where
you're calling the function a certain
functionality within the functionality
so as you can see over here we call the
expression inside the expression itself
so what this aim what this tries to do
is that it tries to ensure continuity so
over here
the term let's say the first term is 5
plus another expression our expression
can be equal to a term plus another
expression so we can say 3 so the three
is a term so we can have three
plus now expression can be a term as
well so 2 is a term so all we're trying
to do is we're trying to ensure
continuity so that we can enable
multiple editions over here so even if
there are thousand integers added
together we can ensure that all of them
uh
uh conform to the grammar rule because
this is a pretty sound and pretty uh
grammatically correct expression five
plus three plus two going on for n
number of
um terms if you still don't understand
what I mean I'm gonna use a much more
easier comprehensible format
so another way to define an expression
would be to say okay its expression is a
term
multiplied or divided
so you see we use the bar in fact I'm
just going to use the symbols
so it's a term multiplied or divided
by another term
like that
now what does this mean this means that
an expression can be equal to just one
term
or it can be equal to a term multiplied
or divided by another term actually that
should be plus or minus that's my band
plus or minus
so an expression can be a term by itself
but this part over here
where we are enclosing uh
let me just get that right these two
enclosures over here
followed by an asterisk represents zero
or more times that means
now let's clean up that yeah that means
this
uh the contents within that curly brace
can be repeated zero or more times the
final that means a term can be a term
plus another term minus another term
plus another term whatever zero zero or
more times then that is effectively what
the Backus now form is saying it's
calling the expression within itself
to tell you that okay an expression can
contain n number of Expressions so we're
using a form of recursion to to tell the
users or to tell the programmers that an
expression can have n number of integers
n number of terms added a subtracted
multiple times now let's define the term
so a term as I said
it can be equal
to just another term or it could be
equal to a term
it could be it could be equal to a
factor
now a factor is just an integer for our
purposes
so a term could be equal to a factor
multiplied by another factor or
multiplied by another term and you see
I'm doing the same thing over here
recursion and just to symbolize the same
thing as I said the multiplication that
means the term can be equal to a factor
multiplied by another Factor multiplied
by another Factor n number of times zero
or more times
so a term could just as well be equal to
one factor it could be equal to two
factors multiplied together three
factors multiplied together and so on so
that's what I'm trying to signify by
calling the term within the term itself
so by calling term over here
I'll just get the out of her drone for
some reason so by calling the term
within the term grammar rule I'm trying
to Showcase that you can have multiple
factors multiplied or divided together
so
as I said a factor can be multiplied by
another term or it could be a factor
divided by another term
or it could be just equal to a factor
now what is the factor for now although
in the later part of this course I'll
bring in another aspect to this factor
definition but for now a factor is just
equal to an integer so it could be yeah
let's just do integer
like that an integer is just a series of
digits but I'm not going to go ahead and
Define that because I'm pretty sure all
of you know what an integer means now
in the set of grammar rules we have some
terminology as well so the integer
although it technically isn't and okay
let's just go ahead and do it so I'm
going to say an integer
is for now let's just say the integer is
singular digit so I'm going to say in
integer is just a digit
0 0
or 1 or 2 or 3 or 4.
right so an integer is just a singular
digit and I'm defining that in this way
just to keep things simple as you all
know a digit an integer can be a series
of digits like three four five is an
integer or one two three is an integer
and so on
so
in this notation in this in these
grammar rules
what is inside the angular brackets is
called a terminal is called a
non-terminal
and that essentially means that a
non-terminal can be defined by by using
a terminal so a terminal in this case is
something like an integer which we can
concretely Define like a digit uh
another terminal in our programming
language could be the operator like plus
or minus is another terminal these can
be concretely defined they are the base
tokens of our
um of our language
so with that knowledge of Bacchus in our
form how does all of this relate to
parsing so as I said backers now form is
a way of defining rules once we have
defined rules things actually get pretty
simple it seems that you're still far
away from having a workable interpreter
which can convert your custom program
and programming language and execute it
it seems that we're far away from that
goal but now that we've defined our
grammar rules things get a lot more
easier so now I'm going to take an
example to Showcase how parsing is
actually done now that we have the
background knowledge of BNF and also
about how parsing introduces structure
so in passing let's say we're trying to
pass the input 1 plus
um let's say one
now the expression using our previous
notation we said that the expression
is equal to terms added on added or
subtracted from each other now a term
can be equal to a factor
a factor being just an integer so in
this case the expression
expression is equal to
um one which is a term plus another term
one plus one and that satisfies our
grammar rule
but even if we have something
complicated
let's say
three
plus five times two
the grammar rule says that an expression
is a term plus another expression
so essentially saying that again I'm
repeating myself but an expression is
just a term added or subtracted from
another expression
n number of times
zero or more times so
the expression over here is equal to 3 3
is a valid
um term
which is equal to a factor in this case
and even 5 times 2 is a valid term
because remember we said the term can be
equal to a factor multiplied by another
Factor what zero or more times so this
is equal to a factor multiplied by
another Factor
so even this input is possible using our
given grammar rules
what do I mean by possible that means
that it conforms to our grammar rules
and such an input can be processed in
the parsing stage
now I'm going to use a data structure
known as a binary tree which I'll talk
about more extensively in the next few
sections
but I'm gonna introduce the binary tree
to talk about parsing
now parsing essentially involves uh
again bringing structure into your code
so let's say we have the expression one
plus two times five
I'm going to construct a tree for this
given input
and the tree
is
the following
so this tree over here we are adding the
integer one
and we're adding the product of 2 and 5
and this is the past Tree in fact the
goal of the passing process is to
generate a tree like this of course we
won't be drawing a tree like this in
Python but we will be representing such
a tree in a list
so how do we represent this tree
specifically
I'm going to write it over here so I'm
going to say one
Plus
two times five
like so
so in this scenario plus is the operator
one is the left node in fact this is
known as the root node I'll talk about
this terminology
in just few sections
but this is the left node
and this is the right node
so over here one is our left node plus
is our root node and right node is 2
times 5. so we have effectively
represented this tree
using this list in Python
in this section of the course I'll be
talking about object oriented
programming and its four main pillars
that make it according to me at least
more Superior than the other paradigms
or the other ways of programming so
the first way is functionally functional
based programming which uses po
functions and functions is just a method
like similar to how mathematical
function works you have an input you
give out an output that's basically it
there's some inner workings to a
function
um it's like a black box you have an
input you have an output but you don't
see what's inside so that's how
functions work and just to give an
example let's say we're trying to
calculate the amount of fuel that you
have left in your car
so we create a function called remaining
underscore field
and this takes in the initial field that
you had the kilometers that you drove
and also the ratio which is like the
gallons per kilometer or whatever unit
you're using liters per kilometer
um the ratio of that and the remaining
fuel would just then be equal to initial
minus
kilometers
times the ratio
so in functional programming or
functional based programming you
separate the data from the actual
functionality you see that we have not
accepted any data like the initial fuel
that he had the kilometers that he had
or the ratio we didn't accept any data
this is just a standalone function a
standalone functionality which can uh
basically work fine I mean even if I run
this right now there'll be no problems
so
uh it can work on its own as well so the
actual
um usability of it comes when we add
some data and the essence of functional
based programming is that you separate
the data from the functionalities now
over here I can give in some data let's
say uh let's say I say the initial fuel
is equal to 50 units the kilometers this
person drove is
um let's say 10 units or okay 10
kilometers and the ratio let's say is 5
units per kilometer five units of fuel
burnt per kilometer drove so then I can
calculate the remaining fuel I can print
it as well remaining Fuel and I can give
the parameters initial kilometers
and ratio and this works fine so if I
run again
this time you see we have okay we have 0
exactly zero let's reduce the ratio here
a bit and let's run that again you see
we have 30 units of fuel still left so
this is a pretty basic example of
functions and it seems fine in this
level but let's assume that you have a
lot of complexity in your application
let's say you're building a website and
you have the authentication aspect of it
you have the payment aspect of it you
have the content management aspect of it
so many entities uh involved now how do
you
because if you have so many entities
involved you'll have several functions
you'll have authentication functions
you'll have um payment functions and all
of them clubbed in this messy file uh
where it just becomes difficult to
handle things and that's where object
oriented programming comes in object
oriented programming divides
it divides
um code into entities called objects so
you can have one object of payments you
can have one object of uh of
authentication one object of content
management one object of uh maybe like
contact or server where you have chat
functionality or something like that I
don't know so
and in object oriented programming you
divide an application into objects these
entities which have their own
um data and their own functionality now
let's try to understand how
object-oriented programming works on the
canvas
so as I said just as a recap let's just
recap what I said uh in operator into
programming also called oop you divide
things into their own entities called
objects so you can have maybe an object
for payments
so it has its own data it has its own
functionality
but it's all enclosed in this own entity
known as payment entity
we can have another entity for let's say
authentication which has its own set of
data its own set of functions completely
different from the payment
and you have authentication over here
and you can go on and on but you get the
point your
um encapsulating data and functionality
into objects which are the basic unit of
object oriented programming and these
objectives represent entities like
payments and Authentication
now in object oriented programming and
inside an object the data is referred to
as properties
and the functions are referred to as
methods
so now that we've understood the basic
gist of object oriented programming
let's try and understand what are the
four main pillars that hold it and make
it such a solid way of writing your code
so the first main pillar of object
oriented programming is known as
encapsulation and it's the basic idea we
talked about in the previous section
encapsulation refers to
basically just start encapsulating uh
Properties or encapsulating data and
functionality into their own entities so
that we can better handle them and it
just enables us to write more cleaner
code so as an example of our own
situation over here we have multiple
entities we have the lexor we have the
parser we have The Interpreter so it
seems wise to use object oriented
programming because it can encapsulate
each of these entities and have allow
designate them their own properties
their own methods their own data their
own functionality so we can have Alexa
which has its own data its own functions
or methods there's alcohol functions for
now because yeah so the data is known as
properties and functions and
object-oriented programming is called
method
are called Methods so this is one object
you can have another object you can have
a parser
which has its own data its own functions
and you get the idea we can have a
similar class for The Interpreter
this is called encapsulation by your
grouping things grouping data and
grouping functionality
the second pillar is known as
abstraction
an abstraction just refers to
simplifying the inner functionality the
inner yeah basically just that the inner
functionality into its own entity like
for instance in our situation over here
all we need to do an object oriented
programming is create a Lexa
which is of the object Lexa and let's
say we tell it to let's say we tell it
tokenize stuff
uh using the methods
so
this is some notation which I'll go over
in just the next section but all this is
doing is creating an object called Lexa
and it's tokenizing the inputs uh the
input expression so as you can see this
is a much this is a very clean way of
writing code because essentially you're
just abstracting away the inner
complexities uh and the inner
functionality of the Alexa all you're
doing is calling the tokenize method and
you have your tokens ready all you're
doing is create calling the lexor object
and you have your own lecture so that is
known as abstraction it allows for core
reusability the loss for modularity and
essentially if you have different
developers working on different tasks
and they really don't know how the other
developers developer is coding his his
stuff so they can use object oriented
programming to communicate they can say
okay this is one component this this
component will give a certain output you
don't need to know how it works inside
it's a black box you don't to know how
it works on the inside but all you need
to know is for a given input you're
getting this output so that's what
abstraction is abstracting away the
complexities making code looks simple
and let's move on now to the third
pillar
the third pillar of object-oriented
programming is known as inheritance
inheritance is a concept that is best
explained by an example so let's say we
are creating a website and each website
has different components it has the home
page the about page and the home page
has different contents in it the about
page is different contents in it but if
you're designing a website you typically
would have the same layout for each page
you'd have the heading you'd have the
body in pretty much similar positions
so inheritance in object-oriented
programming allows you to inherit
certain common properties within object
so what do I mean by this let's say we
have our an object called page it has
properties like heading
body and the images may be
so this is the base class this is
um this is what you are inheriting from
whereas you have maybe another class
like another class like the home class
which is the home page or the about
class which is the about page
and um these classes will inherit
inherit all of these
properties The Heading all of these will
be inherited
by the Home Home object and um
yeah so again the home object would
inherit the properties and the functions
of the page object while having its own
custom functionality which will which it
will add over the page object so that's
basically what inheritance is you have a
fundamental object and other specific
implementations of it like the home page
the about Pitch inheriting from that
fundamental object
this is a theoretical discussion here I
hope you understand what inheritance
mean means in a more theoretical sense
in this course I'll be doing
object-oriented programming in Python so
um I'll be talking about how you
implement inheritance and all of that as
well
and with that knowledge let's move on to
the final and fourth pillar which is
known as polymorphism
so the fourth main pillar in object
oriented programming is known as
polymorphism
and polymorphism is essentially the idea
that so polymorphism is essentially the
idea that you can treat object of
different types so objects of different
types as if they were the same type
so that may sound a bit confusing but
I'll explain it using an example
so let's say we have three types of
animals we have dogs we have cats and we
have Birds
now the common thing about all of these
animals is that they can make a sound so
how can we program a way in which we can
how can we program the sounds of these
animals so maybe for the dog we do make
dog sound
so this is what you would typically do
but now in polymorphism the idea of
polymorphism is that you can make a
common interface now in this instance
the common interface would be an animal
all of three all of these three entities
are a type of animal so the common
interface over here I can Define it to
be an animal
polymorphism allows you to do is let's
say we create a method in animal called
make sound
and now using this common interface you
can add some custom functionality to
this make sound method so maybe the dog
does a woof upon the make sound method
the cat does a meow on the make sound
method and the bird does a chirp on the
mix on method whatever but polymorphism
allows you to call
the same functionality of the dog and
the cat and the bird using the same
method but each of these entities dog
cat embed do it in their own customized
way and that's the idea of polymorphism
which means many forms it's the idea
that you can allow objects of different
types to be treated as if they were the
same type based on a common interface
and the common interface being the
animal so
that's the idea of polymorphism and with
that let's move on to the next section
in this section of the course we will be
talking about the python implementation
of object oriented programming now we've
talked about uh the theoretical aspects
of object-oriented programming in the
previous sections where we talked about
objects how objects Define certain
entity and we group a set of
functionality a set of properties into
each object and we separate them using
object oriented programming so how do
you define an object how do you define
one entity like as I said previously we
can have a payment entity we can have an
authentication entity we can have a
let's say contact page always to a chat
entity in in the example of creating a
website so let's see we're creating a
website all three of these are their own
entities so how do we create these
entities in Python how do we create
these objects in Python
Now to create an object we must use the
pro the at the keyword called class
a class essentially defines a blueprint
for each object so as you might know the
payment will have different set of
functions authentication will have
different set of functions the payment
will have different set of input
parameters it might have the user it
might have the amount of payment the
recipient the donator
the authentication will have different
parameters it will have maybe
um the username the password the ID or
the email address the chat will have
different input parameters so because we
have different input parameters
different functionality for each entity
we must Define a blueprint for each
entity so let's say we create a class
for payment
now as I said we each each entity will
have different set of input parameters
like payment will have the input
parameter payment recipient amount and
all of that and it will have a different
set of functionality maybe to process
the payment authentication will have a
different set of functionality maybe to
check if the password is correct or
something like that so we can Define we
can take in the input parameters for
each class using the init method
it's a special method and this init
method Works in a way that you can take
in the self parameter here now I'll talk
about self in just a second in fact let
me just leave this as pass over here and
I'll create an instance of this payment
method this payment class so I'll create
an object over here I can say payment
one
is equal to payment
and this is where payment one is an
object it is an instance of the class so
it takes in the blueprint defined by the
payment class and it it's an instance of
that so this is an object over here
payment one
is an object
it is an instance
of the payment class
so all of those blue all of the the
blueprint defined in the payment class
the attributes the functionality the
data all of that defined in the payment
class all of that comes into play in
payment one which is an object which is
an instance of the payment class
how do you accept parameters like for
instance let's say I want to pass in the
parameter recipient
the uh amount
and let's stick to two parameters for
now how do you accept these two
parameters in the payment class
so we use the init method for that
and this takes in by default a parameter
called self now self is the same as
payment one so as you might know that
there are you can have different
instances of the same class I can have
payment one for maybe one transaction I
can have payment two for another
transaction
so let's say another transaction will
have will be called payment 2 and this
two will have a recipient these two will
have an amount
so
um payment 2 is also an object of the
payment class now how do you keep track
of each object over here we use the self
keyword for that so self refers to the
instance itself now I can add to that
instance I can say okay now self dot
recipient
equals whatever input parameter given
over here so here we have given a
recipient over here let's say the
recipient is um
I don't know person a and amount let's
say it's 25 units and over here the
recipient is person B
and the amount is
50 units so self dot recipient is equal
to recipient
and what I am doing by this I'm saying
what I'm doing by this is that I'm
saying that uh the payment one object
you add to that payment one object which
is self you add to that payment one
object you add a property called
recipient and make that equal to the
recipient input which is given over here
and to understand what that means I'm
going to print payment one
dot recipient
and if I run this over here
um okay so we also need to take in the
amount
and I'm going to surf dot amount
equals amount
so over here we can see that the
recipient is person a so payment one dot
recipient defines uh the recipient for
this instance
I can do payment 2. recipient
and this will print out B
as you can see over here
so just to summarize a class defines a
blueprint a set of methods a set of data
that can be that pertains to one entity
objects are instances of a class you can
have multiple instances of one class and
you can accept parameters input
parameters from each object by using the
init method which is by default called
when you create an object over here when
I'm creating payment this init method is
called
so you can use the init method to accept
input parameters like recipient and
amount and we say okay now add to the
current object a property called
recipient and make that equal to
whatever value is inputted over here
this is one input this is another input
whatever input parameters provided add
that to the self dot recipient which is
itself add that to that instance itself
so now when we Define other functions
like maybe let's say
um
check balance
by default I have access to self by
default I have access to the instance
itself so now I can have I can say okay
now self uh is the instance itself and
in the init method we added properties
like recipient and amount to the
instance itself so now in the check
balance method I have access to those
parameters I have access to those
variables so I can Sprint self Dot
okay let's say we have an initial amount
and after the transaction I'm gonna
return self dot initial minus the amount
of transaction
so over here let's do uh let's print
payment one dot check balance
and this is initial not self dot initial
so initial minus self dot amount and
let's say initially he had 500 units of
uh cash and now if I pre if I save and
run again you see we have 475 left
so we've called the check balance method
we provided an initial amount and we
subtracted the self dot amount which is
uh which we remember we added in the
init method so hopefully that makes
sense if this is the first time your
learning object oriented programming
this may sound a bit complicated but I
if you still don't understand it I
encourage you to revisit this section
again and hopefully you get in the
second time so after you have understood
what instance variables are effectively
variables that pertain to one instance
like uh the recipient the amount we'll
move on to class variables and class
variables generally are for the entire
class for all of the instances these are
stuff like constants maybe you have a
constant like the dollar to pound ratio
that's one constant and that will be
same for all payments that will be same
for all payment instances so those are
class variables that are same generally
same for all of the instances so let's
learn about class variables in the next
section
so in the previous section we talked
about instant variable instance
variables and how we can create
variables pertaining to each instance of
the original class so over here we set
the recipient and we set the amount of
the transaction for uh each payment and
in that way we created instance
variables because they are pertaining to
each object they were not the same for
all of the instances like for instance
if you make one transaction you will
have a different amount compared to if
you made another transaction so that's
why we created instance variables that
were that were unique to each
transaction to each object but certain
on certain occasions you need to have
class variables wherein there you have
the constant value for all of the
instances and that's the main purpose of
introducing class variables now in this
example let's assume that this class
payment acts like a ledger for an
individual who is making payments on the
internet so let's say he he's making a
bunch of payments on the internet and
um whenever we he makes a new payment an
object is created so payment one
corresponds to one transaction payment 2
corresponds to another transaction so
whenever he creates whenever he does a
new transaction a new object is created
and this check balance uh method is run
to check how much balance is remaining
after each transaction
in this situation we don't need to
call the initial amount for every single
object because the initial amount would
be the same for no matter how many
transactions he does the initial amount
that he started with would be same so in
this scenario we need to use a class
variable to represent this value of
initial initial being the amount of
money he had before doing any
transactions so to do that I can create
a variable over here let's say initial
balance
and let's set that to 1000
and now how do we access this class
variable inside this check balance
method so first of all we don't need to
accept a variable a parameter over here
so we can remove that
and instead of writing initial
underscore balance because even if we do
initial underscore balance you'll see
that we're getting this green
highlighted uh the clo highlighted
problem over here saying that initial
balance is not defined even though we've
defined it over here and that's because
to access a class variable we need to
write the name of the class before the
name of the variable so over here I can
say payment
dot initial balance and in this way if I
remove these the second payment and just
run this command
you see we get that the the remaining
balance is 975 units so that's the basic
gist of class variables and with that
knowledge let's move on to the next
section
in this section of the course we will be
talking about class methods and static
methods so traditionally in these
classes you saw that each method
accepted the instance itself like in
this situation here when we created
payment one which represents a
transaction so in fact I'll just call it
transaction one
so and some trade that as well
I'll remove that for now okay so um
uh in this example we created an object
called transaction one which represents
a transaction and it is an instance of
the payment class so it's an object
which is an instance of the payment
class and each method in this class
accepted the instance itself
the transaction one itself it's as if
the first parameter of each of these
methods is the instance itself and we do
that because in the init method we can
uh assign a bunch of properties to that
instance given these input parameters
over here like recipient and amount and
then we can access those parameters uh
pertaining to one instance in the other
methods as well
but sometimes you don't need to you
don't want the self to be returned you
don't want to have access to the
instance which is transaction one but
rather you want access to the class
itself like say for instance we want to
update this initial balance now one good
way we can do that is we can create a
class method which will take in the
class as an input and then we can update
the class variable over here so for that
we can use a class method and how do you
create that easy use a python decorator
now we don't really need to know much
about python decorators except that they
modify the functionality of our class
method so I'll use the class method
decorator and now whatever method I
Define over here which will be update
initial balance
this method will be modified so that
instead of accepting self it accepts the
class itself and we don't use the
parameter name as class but rather CLS
because that is already reserved for
creating a new class
so update initial balance and let's take
an input as the New Balance let's say
over here
what I can do is I can say class dot
initial balance and that's the same as
doing something like this over here
after the class in line 16
updating the initial balance to New
Balance
is the same as doing the following
payment dot initial balance equals and
if the new balance is 50 like so
so it's effectively the same thing but
we're now creating a class method and
including the functionality inside the
class itself so now if I do transaction
one
or let's do
um
payment
dot update initial balance and I set the
New Balance let's say 800
and then if I print
transaction one dot initial balance
and in fact we can even print it yeah
this works fine
so if I run this now
you see we get 800
so since we modified the payment classes
initial balance all of the instances
initial balance also gets modified and
that's why transaction one's initial
balance is still 800.
uh if we create another transaction it
will also have 800 because it's an
instance of the original class
and since we've changed the class
variable itself even the instance
variables uh feel the same change so I
can even do payment print payment dot
initial balance and we'll get the same
response
if I run this you see we get 800 again
so that's a class method now sometimes
you you need to use static methods and
static methods are basically methods
that do not accept any
um
input parameter by default so in these
in a traditional method in a in a class
we by default accepted the instance in a
class method we by default except the
class but in the static method we by
default except nothing so that's
effectively a simple function but we
want to function inside a class because
it is closely related to the class
so maybe one type of static method we
can add is checking if the transaction
can be held because checking if the
transaction is between the working hours
so maybe that's between 8 AM to 5 PM so
if a transaction is not within those
bounds then we'll have to return false
else we can return true so for that I'm
going to create a static method and the
exact same way we do at static method
and then over here we can say check
valid transaction
and this will take in Nothing by default
but I want to take in two parameters the
hour and let's say the 24 hour system so
I'm going to say if our
is um
greater than 8 greater than equal to 8
and our is less than equal to
um 5 PM which is 17.
I'm gonna say return true
else let's return false
[Music]
so and this works because if the
condition is true we'll return true and
exit this function
and we won't reach this error but if
this condition is not true then we won't
exit the function and we'll directly
return false
so now let's try this so I'm gonna say
let's get rid of this as well
and I'm going to do transaction one
dot check valid transaction
and we're going to say the r is 13.
and let's print this
if we run the file you see we get true
if I given something like 24
or less to 23 24 is invalid
we get false
so
that's the basic idea of class methods
and static methods and with that
knowledge I'm going to go to the final
section of object oriented programming
which will talk about how we can inherit
from parent classes and all of that so
for all of that and more I'll see you in
the next section
so now it's time to talk about
inheritance and how we can inherit the
properties and methods from another
class and to do this I'm going to use an
example of a website
so in our website you have multiple
Pages you have the home page you have
the about page you have the contact page
and I'm gonna create a base class which
is like the fundamental class and that's
going to be the page class so this class
is going to be page
and this is going to have
its own init method so the page class
will take in
um
properties parameters like first of all
we'll take itself by default and then it
will go ahead and take the heading of
the page and the body of the page
so over here I'm going to say self dot
heading equals heading
and self dot body equals body
moving on I'm gonna create a method
called create page so over here I'm
going to create underscore page
and this will just return HTML code of
that page so keeping it very simple
let's just have a header tag and if you
are not sure if you haven't learned HTML
code uh all this is doing is creating a
heading using a header tag and it's
creating the main body text using a
paragraph tag so over here I'm going to
say H1 so this is the heading tank and
within it goes the heading so I'm going
to use an F string to embed self dot
heading here
so whatever the heading is we're gonna
embed it inside the heading tag and then
we're gonna create a new paragraph and
this will contain the body
so
this opens the heading tag this closes
the heading tag and within the heading
tag you have the value of the heading
which remember we assigned to the
instance of the Page by accepting the
heading as a parameter in the init
method
and over here as well same thing we're
going to do it with self.body
over here I'm going to return the HTML
code to
and that's going to be pretty much it
for the page class
now I want to create another class for
the contact page but there'll be a lot
of overlappings the page class is like a
bigger Circle and the contact class is a
smaller Circle within it so the page
class is like the parent class of it
where the contact class has to inherit
stuff like the heading and body from the
page class itself because if okay let's
just assume you're creating a contact
class like this in a simple way then
we'd have to copy all of this code and
paste it again
like so and this is a very inefficient
way of working because uh we have the
page class which is the base class why
don't we just inherit the init method
why don't we just inherit the create
page because they are effectively the
same methods because
um they have the same functionality
contact page is after all a page and
therefore it will inherit some of the
methods and some of the properties like
software heading and self.body and some
of the methods like create page from the
page class so how do you inherit how do
you inherit these properties and methods
from the page class
now in Python you use the following
notation so you go a pair of parentheses
and you write the name of the class you
want to inherit from
and with that all of this code is saved
I don't need to rewrite it again and all
I need to do is plus pass essentially do
nothing in the contact class
and now let's create a contact page so
I'm going to say contact UNESCO page is
equal to contact
and I'll provide a heading let's say
um
contact us
and the body text will be
please give us your feedback
foreign
dot headings let's see what the heading
is and if I run this
okay so I need to print that so let's
print it
and if I run you see we get the headings
contact us so even if we don't have an
init method over here it doesn't matter
the python would first look in the
contact class to see if there is an init
method it doesn't find it it will go to
its parent class which is the page class
and over here it finds in it it finds an
init method and it assigns self heading
to heading it sees that over there and
from that you see that the contact page
instance
gets the heading variable attached to it
and then when we print it we get contact
us as the heading so it first looks in
the contact class if it doesn't find the
net method it will go ahead into the
base class
so another thing we can do is create a
page
We inherited that method so if I run now
you see without any code in the contact
class it doesn't matter we're getting
the same output here because we've
inherited the method and the variable
from the page class
so now with that done I want to talk
about one more thing which is the is
instance
um function the is instance function in
Python is used to check if an object is
an instance of a particular class
I'm sorry for that so let me repeat that
again the is instance
function checks if an object is an
instance of a particular class
like for instance over here
let's print is instance
uh contact page of the contact class
and as you'd expect it says true yes the
contact page is an instance of the
contact class because we have written
contact over here if it's an instance
but another thing we can check for is if
it's an instance of the page class
and if I run this now you'll see that 2
will return true because although it's
not directly linked to the page class
the contact class in helps from the page
class and therefore contact page is also
an instance of the page class so we'll
use this function is instance a lot
during the coding of our um uh of the of
our programming language so it's
important to note the functionality of
is instance
another another thing I want to talk
about is the super function so over here
I'm gonna create
the init method
and let's say I want to accept another
parameter for the contact page let's say
I want to accept the email address of
the person who wants to contact me
now that's not that in the base page
class because not every page would need
to extract the email address but it
turns out that the contact page does
need to do so so over here it'll it'll
extract The Heading first of all self in
heading then body then the email address
and over here
what do I do do I just copy this part
over here
and then do self dot email ID
is this the correct way to do it well
let's try it out so if I um
given an email let's say
um
if I get that email in and let's print
the email ID
if I run this you see this will work we
get the email ID but code repetition is
not always appreciated it's never
appreciated in fact in uh in programming
and therefore to avoid this repetition
of
assigning heading and body to
the
um instance instead of repeating this
since we already have that functionality
in the page class we use the super
function so the super function
calls the init method in the parent
class which is page it calls the init
method and we can pass in parameters
heading and body
so this ensures that the init method is
called in the super class and the super
class is the page class so this is like
saying go to the page class and then run
the init method
and provide the heading and body as
parameters so that's effectively what
the super function is doing
so after we have
um handled heading and body then we do
self dot email ID equals email ID and
let's create another function over here
let's say
I want to create
a contact button
and this will take himself
and all I'm going to do is return
button and then inside the button I'm
going to say
self.email ID
contact now
something like that so if my name is if
the email ID is
ABC email.com then say ABC email.com
contact now and this will be inside a
button so in the edge in HTML the button
tag is used to create a button so over
here
let's do the same thing let's contact
page now we're going to create
the contact button
and let's print
and hopefully this works there we go
button ADC email.com contact now so this
is the power of inheritance we are
adding uh we are extending the
functionality of the base class which is
the page class we're extending its
functionality by adding our own methods
while also inheriting the most
fundamental uh functionalities like
create page and we're also inheriting
the
um
the init method over here previously we
we didn't even have to write the init
method it automatically found it from
the page class and executed that so
that's the power of inheritance and with
that I'm pretty much done with object
oriented programming of course we want
to understand objective object oriented
programming on a deeper level there are
several other Concepts to understand but
I think that we've reached a fast stage
now
where with this base knowledge we can
move on to the next section
so in the next few sections we'll be
talking about data structures and we're
going to start off with lists now lists
are like regular list that we talk about
in common language in everyday language
you can have a list of grocery items you
can add add to the list of grocery items
you can remove something from the list
of grocery items you can add something
at a certain position so let you know so
it maintains a sequential order as well
that means it respects sequence that
means you can
add elements at a certain position uh
you don't it's not just that you can add
them at the last position at the first
position so let's demonstrate everything
about lists in Python so this is the
simplest form of data structure we'll go
on to more complicated forms like
eventually we'll talk about binary trees
so anyways let's start with the list how
do you create a list in Python uh you
first create the name of a variable so
I'm gonna call the variable R short for
array so or let's just call it um
I can't use list because that's a
reserved keyboard so let's just use
um a let's call the list a
and you create a list by using these
square brackets and I can create the
first list by saying one comma two comma
three comma four and that's one list
over there
you can add to the list using the append
method so all of this list in Python are
built-in classes so that means if I
print
is instance
a of the class list and that's a
built-in class if I run this you see it
will return true because it's a built-in
class and when you use these square
brackets you sort of create an instance
of the list class
so over here in that list class there is
a method called append so I can append
let's say a number let's say append five
and now if I print a you see that the
output will be one two three four five
the append method adds three last
element
um there is another method two which is
called insert and the insert does not
necessarily add at the last at the end
of the list it can add things even in
the middle or whichever position you
define it to be
in Python uh the position are defined by
starting with the number zero so this
first element is called is given the
index 0
the second element is given the index 1
and so on so 0 1 2 3 so that's the uh
order so you start off with zero so if I
say print
a square bracket 0 that means I want to
access the zeroth element which is the
number one so we'll get the number one
over here
so um we can insert as I said so I can
insert
a certain data it can be anything it can
be a number it can be text whatever so
I'm gonna into insert the number eight
at position two so that means 0 1 2 that
means it should be after the number
three so let's print a now
and see what we get you see it's um
okay I I reverse the order my button so
we have to mention the position first
and then the numbers of two comma eight
now let's see if it works so if I run
this you see we get it before three so
one two eight and three so at position
two so zero one two so now this is a
position two over here
and follow me following that does the
number three then four and five so
that's the insert method
um for lists I can even add a text here
so we create text using these double
quotes and let's say text and if I run
this
we'll get one to text at the second
position remember zero one two second
position
second position three four five and
that's that's how it works you can
reverse the order so you can have five
first in four second and so on by using
the reverse method so I'm going to say a
DOT reverse
and if I run this you see we get it in
reverse order
we can sort it in ascending order and we
can for now I'm going to say ascending
number of order of numbers so let's say
I have the number 9 here
and I'm going to print it
print a over here before the sort so
before sort
and then I'm going to sort a DOT sort
and then I'm going to print a again
and if I run this
you see I'll get before sort it's five
four three nine two one but after the
Sorting process is stored in the sending
order
another method is the pop method and
this Returns the last element of the
list and also removes it from the list
so if I right now
let's remove all of this clutter and if
I do a DOT pop
and then I print a
let's run this again and you see we get
one two three
and in fact I say if I can say last
underscore element is equal to adopt and
if I print the last element I'll also
get what the last element was so if I
run this you see I get 4 was the last
element and now what remains of the list
a is one two three
so you can also remove all of the
elements by using the clear method so
over here I can do Aid or clear
and if I print a
run it you see we get an empty list
which is symbolized like so
so now
let's move on to a few more operations
one more Opera one operation you have is
let's say I have the D list one like
that
now I can print
or I can do a equals a times five and
now let's print a you may think that
that makes no sense but that essentially
just multiplies this item by Phi so that
means this item will be present five
times now so 5 times 1 is 5 if this was
existing twice then it will add the same
array five times to itself and a would
look something like this so if I run
this you see we get the array with 10
ones because the first base array is
with two ones and then you multiply that
with five and you get 10 months so
that's uh how you can multiply or is you
can even add arrays to each other so if
I one array is one comma two
another array is 3 comma four
now if I print
a plus b
and run this you see we get one two
three four
so that's how we can add or multiply
arrays one more thing you can do is you
can go you can iterate over a range of
values in an array so like say for
instance I have
one two three four five and six
now if I print a
one two three so a one two three
let's see what we get over here so if I
run this CC I get 2 comma 3 and this
starts off from the index one which is
here moves on to index two and it
excludes the last value here so uh if
you want to include the last value you
have to add by once three plus one four
and in that way it will include two
three four like that so let me just
um rephrase again so you have at index
one you have the number two so two comma
three comma four and this is index three
zero one two three and this last is
since it's four over here but
um when you're when you're taking it
over a range it does not include the
last number it does it one minus that so
foreign
returns
the list
from a to the power 1 to a to the power
a 3. so index 1 to index 3 that's how it
works
you can also have
um no number to start and that will
return everything until the index number
three so if I run this you see
everything until index 3 if you don't
specify a number over here if I specify
a number over here it'll be from index 1
to index 3 but if I don't specify it
it'll be from the start to the index 3.
now after that you also have
um copying arrays so how do you copy one
copying list so how do you copy one list
from to another list so let's say I have
this list over here a equals one two
three four five six
now A2 I want to copy uh list one so I'm
going to say a
and uh let's see what happens if we do
this so now if I print A2
you see we do get one two three four
five and six
but check this out if I do A2 dot append
seven
and now I print A2 obviously it will
have the seventh number
after it
but if I print it
and run this again you see even a has
experienced that change so when you
equate these two together even a
experiences the operation zero after
that of after line two if you don't want
that to happen you want to leave a as it
is and work with this as a new array you
can use the copy method so dot copy and
if you do that you see this change does
not get implemented on array a it's only
implemented on array A2
so that's about it for lists
tuples are quite similar to lists in
that they also store data in non in an
ordered manner so you can create Tuple
instead of using by instead of using
square brackets you use the normal
brackets so over here I can say Tuple
one
equals and you use a pair of brackets
over here
and I can have one comma 2 comma 3
I can print the first element of the
Tuple
which is the zeroth index
I can
yeah let's just do that for now
and you see we get one over here so
that's how tuples work it's very similar
to list but they have a few distinctions
that you need to keep in mind
one of the distinction is that a tuple
is immutable so if I try to do the
following Tuple one zero and I'll try to
change the zeroth index so let's say the
number five and I save it you see we get
an error Tuple object does not support
assignment
so this is why tuples are immutable they
can't be changed whereas lists are
mutable so if I do list one equals 1
comma two comma three and then I do list
one
zero is equal to 5 and let's comment
this one out
and I run this you see we don't get any
error over here
and let's just print list one as well
if I run this
you see we get 5 comma 2 comma 3 because
lists are mutable but tuples are not
one additional thing you need to note
about tuples is that if we have a
element if you have a tuple with one
element
then you can
create them by using the following
notation you do not you can't have no
comma over here because if you do
brackets one brackets that will mean
that this is just
a number inside a pair of brackets it
does not resemble anything but if you
put a comma over here you would realize
that that's a tuple so in fact let's try
and see the instances were whether it's
an instance of Tuple or not so let's
print
is instance Tuple one
of double
if I run that you see we get false but
the second I put a comma over here I'm
telling python that this is a tuple I
want to create this as a tuple so if I
run this you see we get true over here
now it's also possible to convert tuples
to lists and list tuples so I'll delete
all of this now
and I can say list one
equals
Tuple or equals list of Tuple one
and if I print list one
you see it will be a list
as you can see
and if I do
this one over here
and let's create a list over here
and I'll do tackle one here
and let's create a tuple from the list
you see that that too will work
we get a tuple over here
so that's about it for tuples let's move
on to the final sort of simple data
structure which most of you might
already be familiar with but I thought
it would be a good idea to give you a
refresher about these data structures
see the last one will be talking about
is dictionaries and then we'll move on
we'll move on to few Advanced data
structures like Stacks or binary trees
which we will be using in this course so
I'll see you over there
so how do you create a dictionary in
Python well we use there are two ways to
do it the first way is a simple one you
just use a curly brace pair of curly
braces and then the first thing you
mentioned in a dictionary is the key so
in a dictionary you have key and value
so you have key value Pairs and an
example of this will be the following so
let's say I have an employee and his
name is John
so over here name is the key John is the
value
this employee will have an age
and you have to also include that in
double quotes and his age is 19.
um this employee will have a profession
let's say it's accounting
so that's this that's how dictionaries
work you have a key you have a value and
these pairs you can have n number of
them in a dictionary stored in a
dictionary so the purpose of
dictionaries is that they can store two
values key they can they can store two
pieces of data key and value and they're
actually pretty useful when for instance
creating Alexa where each token will
have of a data type and a value like for
instance the number five has a type of
integer and has the value of five so in
that sense dictionaries are really
useful because they allow us to store
two pieces of data
how do you access uh values so you can
say dict one
um say the name of the key so let's say
the name
and let's print this
so similar to an array how we use the
square brackets to access a certain
index we will use a square bracket to
access the value of a certain key let's
print this run it
we get John
we can do age
and we'll get 19
and this doesn't necessarily have to be
a string it can also be a number so for
instance let's say 5 is um I don't know
26 okay this makes no sense but I'm just
trying to show how you can also store
the key as an integer as a number so
over here I can access the key 5 and
that will return 26. one more thing you
can do in dictionaries is Traverse
through them iterate through each item
of a dictionary and you use a for Loop
for that
so I can run a for Loop
we can extract the key and the value
indict one by using the items method the
items method is a certain method present
in the dictionary class which is inbuilt
in Python just like the list class and
the Tuple class so over here we're
extracting the key and the value and I
can print that in F string
I can print key with the space bar and
then value
and if I run that you see we get name
John age 19 professional Accounting in a
new line every single time
so that's the basics of dictionaries and
that's all you need to know for this
course and with that knowledge let's now
move on to a few more complicated
Concepts in data structures
in this section of the course I have
brought an interesting activity that you
can do using the existing knowledge that
we've built so far so we are going to
create our own class for data structure
known as a stack now a stack is
effectively just
um it's just like that it's just what
the word describes a stack you can have
items stacked on top of each other you
can add an item at the top of the stack
but you cannot add it in between the
stack like we did in a list where we
added items in a certain position of the
list where we can't do that with Stacks
the only three operations you have is
you can add an item on top of the stack
you can remove an item from the top of
the stack or you can read the value of
the item at the top of the stack so I
have an activity for you how about try
creating a class that performs all of
these uh functionality so we'll have a
class called stack
and it will have an init method of
course but I won't write that for now it
will have three functionalities push
which means adding to the stack
adding an element to the end of a stack
to the to the top of the stack
we have pop
adding an item to the top of this
removing the top most item from the
stack
and you also have Peak
which is reading the value of the item
on the topmost of the stack so these
three functionalities push pop and Peak
can you try executing them using python
list so you will be using python lists
as a data structure to create the stack
so now let's move on to the task how
does this work so I'm going to first
create the init method
which takes in self
and it will yeah that's it self and over
here I'm going to create
the stack now the push method adds an
item to the top of the stack so this
will simply append
to the list
Whatever item so we need to take self
over here first of all and we also need
to take the item that you want to push
to the top of the stack so I'm going to
say item over here we're going to append
item
we can pop as in remove the item at the
topmost of the stack and for that we can
use the pop method in in list so you can
do pop
and I'll also accept selfio
and we can return
self.stack.pop this removes the topmost
item from the stack
Peak we'll just return the topmost item
from the stack now in Python to
extract the last item of list because
ins since we're using list to represent
the stack the topmost item is the last
element of the list so how do you
extract the last element of the list
for that I'm gonna use self first of all
and I'm gonna say last underscore
element
is equal to self dot stack
the length of the stack
minus 1 because the indexing starts from
and in this way we're extracting the
last item of the list which corresponds
to the stock topmost element of the
stack so this is the last element and
I'm going to return that last element
so now let's try working with the stack
so I'm going to say stack one
is equal to stack
and I'm going to stack one dot push
let's push
um
the number five
stack one double push
number three
stack one dot push
the number seven
and now I want to pick I want to see the
topmost element of the stack so I'm
going to print
stack one dot Peak
which is which will Peak at the topmost
element of the stack since the first the
bottom most is five then in the middle
there's the number three and then the
top of the stack is seven we should get
the number seven so if I run this I get
seven over here so that's it from this
section I feel that this was a good
exercise to get us warmed up for our
upcoming challenges in creating the
programming language so with that
exercise let's move on to the next
section where we will be talking about
binary trees
a binary tree is a form of hierarchical
data structure it looks something like
this so you have
um the following placeholders you have a
you have B
C all of these points and these points
represent a storage of data they're
called nodes nodes are
a unit of data
it's a representation of data it's a
placeholder for a day for a piece of
data so B over here C
and then we can do d e
like so and this is a binary tree now a
binary tree means that each node has a
maximum of two children
the child of node a is B and C so this
is the left child
this is the right child
so the children of node a are the left
child and the right child which is node
B and node C and in a binary tree every
node has a maximum of two children as
you can see nodes d and e have no
children and they are called Leaf nodes
node D has two children node C maybe we
can have one child to it
like that so the idea is simple binary
trees have a maximum of two children
every node in a binary tree has a
maximum of two children
a bit of more terminology is the fact
that every single level is given a
number so this is called level one and
it includes only node a
this entire thing is called level two
and this entire row is called level
three
so that's just the uh terminology used
in describing binary trees but what's
the use case of it how does it work
we'll look into that in the next section
the most important part the most
important part of binary trees is a way
in which we Traverse to them the way in
which we visit each node and analyze and
process each node so there are three
ways of traversing a binary tree and
just before we get into that I'm going
to talk about something called a sub
tree so I have the root node over here
uh this is called the root node which is
at the top of the tree
and it has a few children two children
maximum of two children
and every single node after that also
has a maximum of two children until we
get to the leaf node which have no
children
so d
and let's do e over here
so in a binary and I'm going to do one
more F over here in a binary tree we
also have sub trees so this entire
region which is uh enclosed by the
dotted line is a sub tree it's a tree
within a tree
and now that we understand what subtrees
are we can try and understand the
traversal methods how you visit each
node of the tree traversal refers to the
fact that you have to visit above you
have to visit each and every node in a
binary tree so how do you do that there
are various ways in which you can
Traverse through binary tree and we're
going to talk about three ways the first
is called pre-order traversal
pre-order traversal refers to the fact
that you first go to the root you first
visit the root node then you visit the
left subtree
and then you visit the right subtree
so I'm gonna call the subtree over here
subtree one and this subtree will be
2.
so how can we Traverse to this entire
tree
Traverse through this entire tree by
using the pre-order traversal method so
the first step is going through the root
so we start off with node a
then we go to the left subtree so then
we Traverse through left subtree
and then we Traverse through the right
subtree
now we need to understand how we
Traverse to the left subtree which is
subtree one
and we use the same pattern over here we
start off with the root root so we go
from B then we go to the left sub tree
and the left sub tree is just node D so
this is the left sub tree over here
so that's node d
then we go to the right subtree which is
node f
so that's what the pre-order traversal
of subtree one looks like the period of
traversal of subtree 2 will look like
first we start off with the root node
there is no left subtree so we don't do
anything then we move to the right
subtree which is e over here
so in pre-order traversal the order of
traversal is a
B
d
f
c e and this is known as pre-order
reversal
we sometimes use pre-order traversal we
visit uh D3 in such a way to accomplish
certain tasks in our scenario where we
will be
where we want to pass inputs parse uh
inputs in a certain programming language
and then given then execute it we have
we'll be using post order traversal so
let's take the example of an expression
one plus two times three now how does
all of this relate to a binary tree so
we can represent one plus two plus times
three instead of this expressed in a
linear way like a list of tokens which
is what we do after step one after
lexical analysis step two involves
making this linear data structure and
converting it into a hierarchical binary
tree so how can we express this
expression as a binary tree
so we start off with the plus operation
which is the topmost which is the root
node
then we go left
which is the number one
then we multiply 2 and 3.
so this is the binary tree
[Music]
of the expression 1 plus 2 times 3
and the way in which we Traverse it
affects how we get how we evaluate the
expression
so in post audit reversal so we talked
about pre-order traversal in the
previous section now I'm going to talk
about post order traversal
in post order you start off with the
left subtree
then you move to the right subtree
and then you move to the root node
so the left subtree is the following
dotted line the right subtree is also
the following
left sub tree it's just
um so I'm going to call this subtree a
I'm going to call this sub tree B
so subtree a
is equal to just 1
you start new that's the only thing you
can that's the only way in which you can
Traverse subtree a sub tree B if you
want to do a post order traversal on
this you start off with the left subtree
which is the left node over here the
node two then you move to the right
subtree which is node three
node three
and then you do the root node which is
multiplication
so now finally to evaluate the binary
tree we start off with the left subtree
which is a
to be to the root
and that's 1 comma 2 comma 3 comma
multiplication
um yeah comma root so that's the way in
which we Traverse through the Stream
it's called post order traversal and the
idea in personal traversal and how it
relates to Computing or expression is
the fact that the order of operations
with higher precedence lie lower down
the tree and do in Expressions when
evaluating expressions we give
preference from left to right so if you
compute compute seven divided by 2
divided by 3 we compute this first and
then the answer of that we divided by
three so the higher presence is given to
left than the right
so this is one fact and the other fact
is that we give precedence to to
multiplication and division more than
the preference to addition or
subtraction so in this scenario the
order of operations with higher
preference are lower down the tree they
have a higher level so remember this was
level one so they'll be lower down the
tree will have a higher level and by
traversing them in a post-order manner
like one two three multiplication and
then the root node by traversing them in
such a way we are first Computing one
then we are Computing the multiplication
and then we are adding those two
together that's what the effect of post
order is
so now let's understand how post audit
reversal relates to Computing and
expression so let's say we have the
following expression one plus two times
seven
so over here we're gonna have addition
first
or in fact I'm gonna
um do multiplication first because we
already used a similar expression
let's do one times eight plus seven
so plus and then multiplication
one and eight
and seven
so in this example over here let's start
to do Post audit reversal
so remember it's left subtree then it's
the right sub tree and then it's the
root node
so that so the left subtree is the
following
and in here again we have to do Post
audit reversal so the left subtree of
this sub tree is the number one then you
go to the number eight then you go to
the root node which is multiplication
and then again we move to the right
subtree which is 7 over here this is the
right subtree and then we move to the
operation Plus
so that's the post audit reversal of how
this works and now let's try and see how
we can compute an expression using post
order traversal
so
I'm gonna erase this bit
and over here
uh
yeah so over here let's see by following
this order of operation by following
this order of traversal how we can
compute the expression so remember the
first thing we're going to do is visit
the root node the the node one which is
over here the first thing we do is visit
this so we visit this a then the second
thing we do is visit this so B third
thing we do is visit this so C then D
and then finally we visit the plus
operation so e
so we start off with first then eight
then multiplication then seven and then
Plus
so how does this relate to Computing and
expression
so we first visit root uh we first visit
this node over here so I'm going to call
that node a we first visit node a
and we process it so that's the number
one
so we first process that
um so let me keep that over here so one
we first processed that process that
then we go to root B and we process that
we get the number eight so now we've
processed that as well and it's the
number eight
then we go to root C and we process that
okay now we see it's the multiplication
of one and eight so then over here all
we do is 1 times 8 which is equal to
eight
so in multiplication so there are two
types of visiting one you visit a number
in which you just return that number one
or eight the second type of visiting is
when you visit a binary operation over
here plus is a binary operation is
adding two numbers multiplication is a
binary operation it's multiplying the
left child node and the right child node
so when we visit a binary operation we
have to multiply the left trial node and
the right child node so now we visited
the multiplication node which is which
was node C and we computed it it turns
out to be eight times one which is eight
so we visit uh we visit one first we
visit eighth then then we use
multiplication so we're done with this
this and this then we visit node D and
we compute it it turns out to be value
of 7.
7 I'm sorry I just glad had a glitch
over here so after we've processed node
node 7 the the following node over here
after we've processed that then we go to
the root node which is over here and we
do a binary operation we check the left
node we check the right node and we
compute them we add them together and
the output turns out to be 15. so that's
how we will be interpreting our input
expression and this can be replicated
for all of the input expressions in the
programming language like say for
instance we have an input a equals seven
so then the operation would be equals
and then a and then seven then we'll
have to uh Traverse in the post order
method and we'll have the similar output
so that's how we're going to compute
Expressions that's how we're going to
interpret our parse Tree by following a
post order traversal method
and with that knowledge and I hopefully
I hope that you understand how we are
going to compute Expressions because
this is an integral part of our course
so now that you've understood it let's
move on to the next section where we
will be constructing a binary tree and
doing some exercises with them
so in this section of the course we'll
be creating a binary tree essentially
representing them in a programming
language as of now we've just been
drawing them and talking about them in a
theoretical way but now we'll be
creating a binary tree in the Python
programming language
so the first thing we need to do is
create a class for the binary tree
in fact I'll just call it 3 for now
and this will have the init method
and it will take in a root node to start
off with and the root node I'm going to
assign it the value of let's say 5. but
I don't want to work with just numbers
for now because I know that nodes
denotes can also represent other pieces
of data so to represent a node I'm going
to create its own class so I'm going to
create a class for the node as well
the node class
the node class will accept one parameter
it will be the value of the node and I'm
gonna say self dot value is equal to
value
and the node has two parts as you
remember in a binary tree a node can
have a maximum of two children so I'm
gonna represent the left child
by initially none so initially the node
has no children
and the right child will also be equal
to none
now let's go back to the tree and let's
set the root to be equal to a node with
the value of the root so over here we
can create our first basic Tree by
saying okay the tree is equal to an
instance of the class tree and the root
node will have a value of the number
five
so this is just creating the number five
it has no left node it has no right node
for now
but let's add those parameters in so I'm
gonna say tree
dot root so the root uh variable now
we're accessing that since it's uh it
has a class of node I have access to
these parameters left and right so I can
assign these values I can say
three dot root dot left is equal to 3
and 3
is equal to node three let's do node
three
and three dot root dot right is equal to
node 4.
what is the effective representation of
this this has five at its root
and
it has three as the left child
the right child of this node is 4.
so this is the diagram this is the tree
diagram
um that we have created using python
code so there is a tree it has the root
of 5 and that's just a node with left
and right assigned to be 3 and 4 and the
left and right nodes of 3 and 4 are by
default sent to none so that's how we
can create a binary tree in Python now
let's go ahead and do pre-order
traversal on this tree
to perform pre-order traversal I'm going
to create a method called pre-order in
the tree class itself so I'm gonna say
def pre-order
and this will take in self and the first
parameter the first parameter it will
take is the starting point of the
pre-order and this will be the root node
but as you will see we will change the
starting node and we'll be using some
recursion in this algorithm so uh yeah
so the starting dot initially will be
the root node but we take that as a
parameter and another thing we're gonna
take is the records field and I'll
explain what this means in just a second
but for now I'm gonna say if the
starting point is not none which means
if the starting point exists because
remember for the left and right notes we
set them as none so all we're checking
is if they're not none that means if the
starting point exists if the node exists
itself then the first thing we're going
to do is we're going to append that node
to the records list so the records over
here corresponds to a list which will be
an empty list for now and over here
we're going to append it
uh the start dot value
so
let me talk about what this means again
so remember in pre-order traversal we go
in the order of root
then we go to the left subtree
and finally we do the right subgrade
so in this case let's look at the uh the
diagram so it's five the three diagrams
so it's 5 starting off with five
then we go to 3 in the left node
and then over here
4 in the right node so we want to start
off with the root so the in the
pre-ordered traversal over here we're
going to start call to pre-order so I'm
going to say tree
dot pre-order and I'm gonna pass in D
root first so I'm going to say three dot
root that is the starting point and
Records will be an empty list so now
let's see what happens so the first
parameter is three dot root second
parameter is an empty array so tree dot
root is the starting point and start is
not none and therefore it will append
the starting point which is the root
itself to the records records will be
tracking our visits so the order of
wizards that will track the order in
which we Traverse through the nodes so
the first thing that will be appended to
the records list will be the root itself
and that confirms that uh pertains to
our rule of pre-order reversal where we
start off with the root so indeed by
printing I'll be by appending the
starting point value which is roots
value to the records list we are abiding
by the rule set by pre-order reversal
now let's go ahead now we want to do
pre-order traversal upon the left
subtree because remember when we were
Computing a pre-ordered reversal we
started off with the root then we went
to the left subtree and we did pre-order
traversal within that left subtree so
now to compute the left subtree we need
to do pre-order traversal in the left
subtree so I have to do records equals
pre self dot pre-ordered reversal so we
have to do a pre-order traversal on the
left subtree itself
so the starting point now won't be the
root it will be the left node left child
of the root so I'm going to say start
dot left
so over here the starting point is root
I am going to say start dot left we want
to do a pre-order traversal on the left
subtree itself so this is where
recursion comes in recursion is the act
of calling your own function inside the
function so we're calling the pre-order
method inside the pre-order method
itself so over here we're doing uh start
dot left so we want to do pre-order
reversal on the left child on the left
subtree so
how will this look like so we start off
with five then we go left and we start
off with number three and we do
pre-order traversal on the sub tree over
here so right now there's no subtree but
let's say there was so I'm gonna move
them
to the right
and over here
I'm going to add one final uh item it's
going to be let's say the number two
and over here
we have
um two child nodes for this node three
and let's say eight so over here
we start off with the root tone append
that to the records array and the first
thing we have is the is the root perfect
River it's working perfect
so now we move on to the left subtree we
do pre-order traversal upon this node 3
over here
and that will call again that itself
will call start dot left so it will do
pre-order traversal on this left subtree
itself so we are calling pre-ordered
reversal on the left sum trees until we
hit a leaf node until we eat a leaf node
well self dot left is equal to none and
we break out of this
so that's the power of recursion so now
we're going to do records so remember we
had to compute root then left subtree
and now we're going to do right simply
so records equals pre-order
start dot right
and over here I also need to provide the
records list itself as an input
so now let's see how this works so I'm
gonna
list
and I'm going to print the output given
and if I run this file
you see we get five three four so okay I
shouldn't have deleted that comment over
there so I'll just copy all of this and
bring that tree
okay there we go
so let's paste all of that again so this
is how the tree looks like five three
four so we start off with the root note
then we move left we compute that left
subtree then we move right we compute
the right sub tree so from root the left
and then right even if we have a more
complicated three like for instance
we're gonna add uh let's say we had that
the left sub tree within the node three
so let's create that over here we're
going to say tree dot root dot left
which is node three for that node we're
gonna add another left and that will be
node
node two
and then three dot root dot left dot
right it's right child will be equal to
the node eight
so even if we have this complicated
expression how would the pre-order
traversal work we'll start off with the
root then we'll compute the left subtree
and we'll do pre-order traversal on that
left subtree so we go from root against
5 3 and then we start off let's subtree
which is 2 and then eight so we should
have the expected output to be 5
then compute left subtree so that's
we compute left sub 3 using pre-order
traversal so that left subtree is three
to eight so this is the left subtree
over here
uh if I can highlight just that part
okay if I can't do that right now but
let me delete that so the left subtree
is this so how do we compute that left
sub tree using pre-order traversal we
start off with the root so three then we
go to the left subtree of that left
subtree which is two then we move to
right
okay and here it was I believe the
number four
and then we move on to the right subtree
which is the number four and this should
be the order of pre-ordered reversal so
if I save and run you see we do get five
three two eight four so this is what
recursion looks like now if you still
don't get it it's perfectly
understandable because this is a
complicated concept to grasp initially
so I recommend you to move on to the
next section understand recursion how
recursion works and we'll be looking at
a few algorithms dealing with recursion
and then come back to this section where
we will be talking about pre-order
traversal again so in the next section
we'll be doing post order traversal and
then after that we'll do uh recursion
we'll talk about recursion and the types
of recursion algorithm algorithms so for
all of that and more I'll see you in the
next sections
now I'll be doing the post order
reversal which is quite similar to the
pre-order traversal but except remember
the fact that we have root over here
that line corresponds to appending to
root appending the route to the records
list this is the left subtree
feel like I've said that or not but uh
yeah that's what recursions about doing
things again and again so left subtree
and this is the light right sub tree so
this was the order in which we created
the pre-order method
and over here now to do Post order
remember that's just left right and then
the root so all we have to do is say
Define post order
in fact I'll just copy all of this
and starts with self start and Records
and let's paste
and over here instead of putting
records.pend first instead of
registering the root first I'm gonna
register the root last
so now let's try post audit reversal of
this uh binary tree so I'm going to
print three dot post order
tree dot root starting at the tree dot
root and an empty array
so if I run this you see we get um okay
we get none because I did not return so
let's return as well let's return the
records
and now let's run and you see we get a
different order of traversal remember
the tree order traversal for uh post
order
so how does post order work you start
off with the left sub train okay this
seems to be a problem
it should start with two and then move
on
to write and then to the operation I
think I have made a mistake over here
okay yeah so
yes so I forgot to change this to post
order because we will be calling the
post order instead of pre-order so I'll
do Post order here and if I run this
again you see we get the correct order
of operations we start off with two then
we move on to eight then three then four
and then five
so I'll do this one last time I'll give
this a complete summary of the
explanation if you've understood this
completely congratulations you can move
on to the next section where we will
talk about recursion but uh I'll just I
just want to summarize pre-order and
post order one more time so pre-order
this is how it works we have created
this tree
then we have the condition check if the
stock is none or not root is no is not
none so then we move into
uh this if statement we append the route
because pre-order starts off with the
root then the left subtree and then the
right subtree so we append the route
first to our records array and the
records array symbolizes the order of
visits that we've done so we first
append the root then we go down here and
we say records equals self dot pre-order
and we're essentially doing pre-order
reversal on the left subtree itself so
start dot left now we make this the root
and three to eight we make that the left
subtree and we do pre-order traversal on
it itself
then we do pre-order traversal on the
right subtree and then we finally append
the records uh then we finally return
the records so that's how pre-order
traversal Works post order is the same
thing except we do the root at the last
so I hope you get that and in the next
section we'll talk about recursion
so to get you more familiar with
recursion I have prepared two problems
in programming one is the Fibonacci
sequence and the other is counting to a
certain number so hopefully these two
exercises will help you understand
recursion which we will be using a lot
in the later stage of this course so the
first problem is the Fibonacci sequence
now if you're not aware the Fibonacci
sequence is a sequence of numbers that
starts off with the first numbers being
one
and after that the from third number
onwards
the any nth number you take any nth
number it's equal to the sum of its
previous two numbers so the third number
is the value three okay sorry the third
number is the value 2 because 1 plus 1
is 2. now the fourth number what is the
fourth number equal to it's the number
two plus the number one which is three
the fifth number is the number three
plus the number two which is five so
that's how you construct a Fibonacci
Sequence now how do we come up with a
program that will tell you the value at
a certain position that given a certain
input like for instance the number four
it will give spit out the value the
number three
so how can we come up with other such a
program given an input of the position
of the Fibonacci sequence it outputs the
value of that Fibonacci Sequence so how
can we come up with such a program so
first of all I'm going to use a function
I'm going to call create a function
called Fibonacci
and it will take in the position
and it will return the uh
value at that position
so we're going to use recursion to solve
this problem now let's take any position
like this is the fourth position at the
fourth position you're summing the
second position and the third position
values so we can Define Fibonacci the we
can say Fibonacci or let's say output
is equal to the Fibonacci
of the previous position position minus
one
plus the Fibonacci
of position minus 2.
so we have an output we are recursively
calling again this is recursion because
we are calling a function inside a
function we are saying okay the output
is equal to the Fibonacci value at
position minus 1 plus the Fibonacci
value at position minus two so at
position 4 it's the one previous to that
which is the number two and two times
previous to that which is the number one
so one plus two equals three
now this works for most cases but except
for the first two scenarios where the
first two scenarios
the output is just equal to one so to
handle this case I'm going to say okay
if the position
is greater than 2 or let's say greater
than or equal to 3
from here if it's greater than equal to
3 then we're going to use this
expression else if it's not greater than
or equal to 3 then I'm just going to
return the number one because in that
case it's either one or two and for both
instances the output is one so we're
using recursion to
um handle to solve the Fibonacci problem
we can return the output given a certain
input so now a better way to write this
is I am going to say output equals one
output equals the following if it's
greater than or equal to 3 output equals
one if that's not the case and then at
the end I'm just going to return the
output
so let's see let's test this out
I'm going to say
uh this response is equal to Fibonacci
and let's say for the first number and
that's pretty simple that should
hopefully this uh respond with the
number one and I'm going to print the
response
so if I run this you see we do get one
pretty simple even if we do two we
should get the same answer one
now if I do 3 we should get the number
two so let's see if that works
I run you see we get the number two
if I try the number four
we should get three and indeed we do get
three and if I try five we should get
five
as you can see over here let's try one
more
uh sixth number would be five plus three
which is eight so if I do six here
we'll get eight
so that's how recursion works and uh to
be honest this is not a very efficient
algorithm because uh we'll have to
eventually as the num as the input as
the input number increases to maybe 40
or 50 this thing will take a lot of time
to process so 45 if I input 45 over here
you see It'll take like a few seconds to
process we're waiting for the output
still waiting for it and uh
yeah I'm still waiting for it and this
will take a lot of time actually so um
let's try out just let's let's just try
40.
45 seems to be taking a lot of time
so let's try 40 over here and even this
2 will take a few seconds
waiting for the output still and
yeah there we go we get it after a long
period of time I think that was like
seven or eight seconds so yeah so you'll
clearly see that this is not very
efficient
uh a more efficient way of solving this
problem would be to save
um the Fibonacci value at any position
that you compute so if you compute the
Fibonacci uh value at a certain position
you save it in a data structure like a
dictionary or something like that so
that eventually when you need that same
value when you want to refer to that
same value you can quickly refer to it
instead of computing it again in the
Fibonacci function
so then that trick is also known as
memorization it's part of dynamic
programming but I won't go too much into
it because it's not very relevant to our
course
so yeah with that knowledge we've talked
about recursion I'm going to go through
one more problem and that'll be in the
next section our second recursion
problem deals with counting to a certain
number so given the input 7 I want uh
the program to count to seven so it
should output one and then two and three
and then four and then five all the way
up to seven so to create this we have
I'm going to use the function count to
num
and a very simple approach which is the
iterative approach and it's pretty
simple to understand as well is to run a
for Loop now I hope you might be
familiar with for Loops so in a for Loop
you say for I in range num
plus one in fact because the bound is
not inclusive it's exclusive so we need
to add by one and then I'm just gonna
print I
so that should work and if I run this
let's count let's call this function as
well I'm going to say count num
count to let's say 10 and let's run this
and you see we get one two three four
five in fact I don't want it to be from
zero so I'm going to say one to num plus
one and let's run it this time you see
we get one two three four five six seven
eight nine and ten so that's the
iterative way of solving this problem
iterative way I can say that before it's
the iterative way of solving this
problem now let's come to the more
complicated and to understand recursive
way but hopefully it makes sense to you
after this section
so over here I'm gonna create the same
function count to num
this will take an input parameter now
and we want to use a recursive way to
solve this problem
now bear with me while I'm quote this up
I'll explain how what it all means so
first I'm going to check if the number
is greater than zero
that's the first thing I'm going to do
and if it is greater than 0 then I'm
going to count to num calling the
function again with the num minus 1
and then I'm going to print the number
and finally I'm going to count to num
let's say 10 let's run this
and you see we get the same output 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 and 10. so okay what what
does all of this mean now
in fact to make it more simple I'm going
to use a number two first if you
understand this you'll understand it for
any number so let's run this again and
the output should be 1 and 2. 1 and 2 as
you can see over here
so we start off with count to number two
we give that as an input the number is
equal to 2 and in this case the number
is greater than 0 2 is greater than zero
so then we count it up again so we say
count to num num minus one at this stage
within this Loop now what is num equal
to num is equal to 2 but we're counting
to num
count underscore 2
underscore num 2 minus 1 which is one so
now recursive function we again count
num we go back here is 1 greater than
zero yes one is greater than zero and in
this situation num is equal to one and
now we count to num to zero
okay bear with me for a second so num
equals one and then we count to num we
count to zero because one minus one is
zero okay now we count them to zero
we enter this function again is 0
greater than zero no it's not greater
than zero then we're gonna exit now over
here we come back to this original
situation where we had num equal to one
and count from zero well count to num
zero just return you just exited the
function because number is not greater
than zero so now we have processed line
three we move on to line four what is
num equal to num is equal to one at this
point so it prints one okay we can now
num is one now in the previous situation
remember numbers two and count numbers
one so after the after the after we
process this num and after we exit this
function we go back to the original
position when count the numbers two num
was equal to two and count number is one
this line was processed just like before
and num is two so we print two so print
one and then print two
it's it's difficult to understand
initially
but essentially what it's doing is it's
counting uh it decrements so it goes
from count to one so in the scenario but
the count column is 10 we go from 10 to
9 to 8 to 7 to 6 to 5 to 4 to 3 to 1 to
0 when we hit zero num is not greater
than zero and then we go back to the
position in counter num is one now uh
let me go back to the position where we
print RAM and then count alarm is one
and we go all the way up so while
counting up decreases from 10 to 0 the
uh printed output goes from one to ten
so that's how recursion works it's
definitely a much more difficult way of
counting to a certain number but
hopefully it makes sense to you now
um after these two requesting problems I
encourage you to revisit the pre-order
and post order uh functions that I
talked about in the binary tree and
after we've understood all of that it's
time to move on to the next section of
the course so I'll see you there
so in this section of the course we'll
start by building our Alexa which as
I've talked about in the previous few
sections uh decodes the input string so
let's say we give the input expression 5
plus 3 our Pro this is a valid
expression a valid input expression
because our programming language should
be able to do basic arithmetic so given
this input the lexor or the tokenizer
should be able to do lexical analysis
and convert this into a list of tokens
um five plus and three it should ignore
any spaces like that and yeah that's the
basic functionality of our lecture
when we are making up making our
programming language more extensive we
are trying to include more functionality
like strings or assignments variables if
statements while loops and all of that
kind of interesting stuff when we're
doing that are we'll have to update our
Alexa constantly but for now I'm going
to create Alexa that will be able to
process these numbers and these
operations plus minus multiplication or
division so for that I'm going to create
a class called Alexa
and this class will have the init method
it will take itself
which is the instance and it will take a
second parameter which is the input text
now over here I'm going to set text
equal self.text equal to text
essentially when I create the Alexa so
if I do lecture equals Alexa and I give
an input expression 5 plus 3. I'm
assigning a property called text to self
self being the instance itself and the
value of that property will be equal to
the input given over here which is 5
plus 3 so that's what I'm doing with
this line self.txt equals text
now the next thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to create a variable called
idx and set it to 0.
idx is the index of
um
of because when we're creating the rexer
we'll have to iterate through each item
of this um so this there's an input
string over here we'll have to go
through each character and to keep track
of which character we're currently on
I'm going to use this idx it's initially
going to be 0 because indexing starts
from 0 so if I uh the zeroth index of
the string is equal to 5 the first index
is equal to the space bar second index
is this plus symbol and so on
now I'm going to create a variable
called tokens
and that will be just an empty array
where we will store all of our tokens
now after that I'm going to set the
current character Char and that will be
equal to the tokens uh that'll be equal
to the text
idx self.idx so initially the current
Char will be the number five the current
character will be the number five then
uh we'll have to create a function
called move which will which will move
to the next uh idx it will increment the
index and once the index is increment
incremented it will update the character
the character will be this so the
character keeps track of self.char keeps
track of the current character
and after that I'm going to create one
more
property and I'm going to say self dot
token is equal to null and this will be
the value of the current token and
you'll see what this means in just a few
minutes
so after we've created the init method
I'm going to create a method called
tokenize
which will convert this input text into
the output tokens and this will take in
self as usual
now to iterate through each character of
the string I am going to use a while
loop and I'm going to say while the
index is less than the length of the
text
um let's just do print self.index for
now and if I run this and if I do Alexa
Dot tokenize
and if I run this
you see okay so I I forgot to uh
increment it so let's just increment
over here
and if I run this
you see we get 0 1 2 3 4 0
[Music]
fold so we are going through each index
of um
of this input expression so let's remove
all of that for now and now the first
check I'm going to do so there are two
data types as of now there's the number
and there's the operator now a number
Can it can be composed of multiple
digits it can be this as well even this
is a valid expression so
a number can compose of a string of
digits a combination of digits so one or
more digits that's what defines a number
so if we encounter a digit so if the
current character
is a digit now how do we check if it's a
digit I'm gonna have to store all of the
digits that exist let's say self dot
digits equals zero one two three four
five six seven eight nine so these are
all the digits and then I can check if
the current character is in self dot
digits that means if it's if it's 0
that's in self dot digits if it's 7 it's
in self dot digits if it's eight it's in
self dot digits now a better thing to do
is since self dot digits the digits that
exist is universal it doesn't change for
each lecture that we create so a better
thing to do is make this a class
variable instead of an instance variable
so over here I'm going to create digits
and I'll just copy this string over here
let's paste that let's remove that line
and I'm going to do instead of doing
self dot you just I'm going to do Alexa
dot digits so if the current character
is in Lexington digits for instance the
first character is 5 it is in like
certain digits then I need to extract
the entire number the token is not just
the number five the token is the entire
number 5885 so we need to create another
method that upon uh enter upon facing a
number upon facing a digit this method
will extract the entire integer the
entire number
so to do that I'm going to say
uh the current token self-draw token
which is set to none I'm going to make
it equal to self dot extract number
so let's create this method over here
extract number
so this extract number is if the current
character is in digits like over here
it's the number five extract number will
extract the entire number 5885 so to do
that we're gonna uh first of all store
the number as a string
and then while the current character
is in a self dot digits
lecture or digits my bad because this is
a class variable
and that's it for now and also I want to
ensure that we are still in the within
the text so we're not the index is not
greater than the length of the text and
self dot index is less than the length
of self dot text
if this is the case then I'm gonna add
the number
add the current character to the number
now how do I increment the index
so okay so when we hit the digit we call
Self DOT number as self x dot extract
number and then 5 the current uh
character is 5 so that will be added to
the string over here and the string will
be 5. now how do I increment the index I
can't just do self dot index plus equals
1 because I then also have to update the
current character
so I can do self Dot
character equals self dot text self dot
idx so updating it but we'll this is a
common functionality we'll have to do
this a lot of times we'll have to move a
lot of times we'll have to move to the
next character a lot of times so to move
to the next character I'm going to
create a method itself let's call it
move
and I'm going to say self dot idx plus
equals one
and if the self.idx is less than the
length of the text
then I'm gonna increment then I'm gonna
update the value of the character
set that to self.txt
uh at the index position of the updated
index which is plus equals one so
whatever the index was before now it's
incremented by one and the character is
the next position so instead of doing
this I'm just going to call Self dot
move
so that's our while loop essentially we
still have to detect
um floating Point numbers which have
decimal points in them but we'll talk
about that in just a few minutes
so as of now I've set the number and
then I can't just return the number over
here
because remember we want to store tokens
tokens have two aspects to them they
have the value and the type so now the
type over here is an integer and the
value is a number wouldn't it be better
if we had a different class itself for
the token where uh instead of returning
number I can just return the token
itself and given the number and the type
let's say integer and that's it that's
all we return and the token class
handles the rest
so for that I'm going to create another
class let's call it token and I'll
remove this over here
let's create class token
and over here we're gonna have an init
method
this token pass will have a value and a
type
let's let's do type first that makes
more sense
and over here I'm going to say self DOT
type equals type
self dot value
equals value
and I'm gonna do one more thing instead
of returning a token I'll I'll just
return
um another class which is the class of
an integer
so I'm going to create a class called
integer and this class will inherit from
the token class
so
and I'll pass over here so instead of
returning the token all I'm going to do
is I'm going to return the integer
itself the integer class itself now why
am I doing this because the first of all
integer floating points strings and all
of these numbers inherit from The Base
Class token because all of them have a
type and a value so that's why I'm doing
the inheritance and why I'm creating all
of these subclasses the integer float
strings is because these subclasses may
have their own methods like for instance
the integer class may have methods like
converting an integer to a float the
float class may have a method to convert
a floating Point number to an integer so
these classes will have their own custom
methods if we have a class of a string
which we will create later on this class
string will also again inherit from the
token and this class string may have its
own additional functionality like for
instance you have to concatenate two
strings so this will we can write the
method for concatenating two strings
inside this class itself so that's why
it's better to create these classes and
have them inherit from the main token
class
now
um if if I use the integer class over
here and I have to pass the type and the
value so the value will be number
and type will be integer
um like that now my problem with this is
that even though I have defined the
integer class I still have to pass in
and that will always be the case so this
is a form of code repetition how about I
just passed the number and the integer
class manages to do the rest
so for that I'm going to use the super
function so I'm going to call the init
method again
and this will take in just one parameter
of the value
and in the integer path itself I'm going
to hard code the value int as the type
so I'm gonna you do super which is the
token class now in the token class I'm
going to call the init method
and the type will just be integer and
the value will be whatever is passed
over here so what am I doing with this
I'm saying okay extract number and uh
I'm gonna return a type integer the
value of that integer is number over
here which was which we extracted that
is the value of this integer now over
here when the init method is called when
we create this class when we create this
object the init method is called and in
this init method the super classes init
method is called which is the token
class and here we assign type as int and
value as value which is whatever is
given over here instead of passing in
hint every single time we create an
integer which is a form of code
repetition and is not varying it is not
very efficient
now let's try and handle floating Point
numbers as well
floating
now let's try and handle floating Point
numbers as well so a floating Point
number will have a dot in them a decimal
point in them and so I'm gonna first
create a check is float as false
because whether it's floating or not
will depend on our output if it's a
floating Point number we'll return a
class of a float we'll return the float
object and if it's not a floating Point
number we'll return the integer object
so over here is float is false and if
the current character is in digits or
self.char
is equal to a decimal point
so this is possible as well and if this
is the case I'm gonna say
um if self.r is equal to
a decimal point that I'm just going to
do is float equals true
and I'm gonna add the current character
as usual and now over here I'm gonna
return the integer class if is float is
false that means if not is float this is
a way of checking if is float is false
if not is float I'm gonna return an
integer else if its float is true that
means the number is a floating Point
number then I am going to return a class
of float and given number and now let's
create the same class again I'm going to
create a Class A float
and the data type over here let's do FLT
standing for float so that's integer
that's float what next now in the next
part we have to also talk about
operations so the in car as of now
arithmetic Expressions we can input
numbers we can input operations so we
need to deal with operations as well
over here so I'm going to do L if
um the current character
in Alexa dot operations
and let's store operations over here
operations is equal to plus minus divide
multiply
so over here let's say self.token since
these operations don't span for multiple
characters like the digits they spanned
for multiple characters you had five six
seven or six seven eight three the span
for multiple characters six seven and
eight three but the operation is just
one character so we don't need to call
an external method over here all we can
do is say search token is equal to first
of all we need to create the operation
class but the value will just be equal
to the current character
so now let's create the operation class
this will inherit from the token class
as usual
self and value now let's call Super
and in the init method
I'm gonna pass operation up
and the value will be whatever is passed
so now I think this is pretty much it
let's try and run it and see how it
works
actually one more thing I forgot to do
is I forgot to return the token
from the tokenized class from the
tokenized method so let's go ahead and
return self.token and now let's see if
this works so I'm gonna run this
and I'll create a shell in fact a
shell.py
and the shell.py will be used to
interact with our programming language
using the terminal over here
so first I'm going to import from the
lexap class I'm going to from Lexa
import Lexa
then I'm going to say tokenizer is equal
to Lexa
and over here I'm gonna run a while loop
essentially taking input and input
expression uh indefinitely until the
user quits the program so while true
tokenizer equals Elixir and we need to
take an input expression so let's say
text equals input
Shadow script that's the name of our
programming language if you remember
so this is the input we're taking we
will pass that input as a parameter to
the lexer mac object to the Alexa class
and over here I'm gonna do tokens equals
tokenizer Dot
tokenize
and let's print the tokens so if I run
this and let's do one plus one
okay so it's still indefinitely uh
present over here I think I made a
mistake I did not move
uh after the operation so over here in
the extract number method I move to the
next character and uh that we don't need
to add another Movement we don't need to
call move over here again after line 15
but in Lexington operations I did not do
that so I'll have to do search the move
again and now let's run this see if it
works
I have to quit the program first
and let's run let's do one plus one
and okay another problem here we don't
have to return self token with returns
after tokens and over here in the while
loop after we've
um uh received the next token I'm gonna
append to its F1 to the tokens list
so append self dot token so hopefully
now it makes more sense let me just
recap we run a while loop we extract the
token uh the token can either be a digit
or an operation and once we find that
token we append it to the SAS dot tokens
list and then we return self dot tokens
so now let's run it hopefully it works
this time
if I run and the one plus one okay we
get a list and these are the classes
over here integer operation and integer
again
now this is a way an ugly way of looking
at uh the classes so I'm gonna use
another special method called the
representation method and I actually
forgot to talk about this in the uh in
the object oriented implementation
object-oriented programming
implementation but essentially what this
does is if I print the class itself
the representation will be printed so
now when I print the class I get this
ugly representation but I can customize
that representation using the repr
method
and the representation will just return
the current value
in the self.token pass and since all of
these subclasses inherit from that these
two will have the same representation
so let's run it again
if I run it now and do one plus one
you see we get the tokens one comma plus
comma 1. now a problem we'll hit is if
we use spacebars so if I do one space
one we haven't dealt with spacebars we
haven't told the program how to process
face bars so if I run this we'll see
that
we don't get any output so to handle
this issue I'm gonna create a list of
stop words and stop words are just
chunks that you ignore because they're
irrelevant to your program so over here
I'm going to create stock quotes and for
now stop for the only stop code Will Be
A spacebar
so over here I'm gonna say l if
self dot character is in lexa.stop words
in this case I'm going to move to the
next character
and I don't want to append anything so
I'm just gonna break out of this
iteration and move to the next iteration
so I'm gonna hit continue
so now
if I run this again and now I do one
plus one you see it still handles if I
have multiple space bars it doesn't
matter
we still get the same output
so that's basically it and apart from
that yeah okay so that's basically it
for the Alexa as of now we've handled
floating Point operations as well
and even I can do I can even do one
prime two plus seven point eight and
that two will work
I can do 7.5 multiplied by 3 and that 2
will work and you see we are lecture is
working perfectly fine and this is a
good base template to work from now
whenever we have to add additional
functionality like variables if
statements and while Loops all we have
to do is modify these classes modify the
um while loop over here the contents
inside the while loop and will be done
so that's about it for this section
hopefully you understood all of the uh
code related to Lexa and now we'll move
on to the parser how we can create a
pass tree okay how we can create a tree
to represent these arithmetic operations
and then finally in The Interpreter
we'll Traverse through the tree and
compute the operations so for all of
that and more I'll see you in the next
section
so in this section of the course I'll be
working on the parser which will create
a list representation of the binary tree
so you remember how we talked about list
representations and binary trees in the
theoretical aspects of how the passer
worked so it's good to just review that
section but as just as a quick reminder
let's say we have the expression 1 plus
2 multiplied by three the parser will
create a binary tree using just lists
one plus and then it will have a nested
list inside of it 2 multiplied by 3 and
this is effectively the list
representation of the binary tree where
the following highlighted bit is the
right sub tree and this is the left node
and plus is the root node so now let's
create the class I'm going to say class
passive
and over here I'm going to define the
init method
which will take in self and the tokens
and over here I'm going to say self dot
tokens equals tokens
now one more thing I'm going to do just
like how we did it in the Alexa I'm
Gonna Keep An idx and I'm also going to
create a move method to keep track of
our tokens previously in the lecture we
did it to track the current character
now we're going to do it to track the
current tokens I'm going to say self.idx
equals 0 and then self.tok token equals
self dot tokens
on the current idx now let's define the
move method as well
this will increment the idx
and it's going to do if D self dot idx
ft index is less than the length of the
tokens
only then is it going to update the
token value
so
now let's go ahead and create the method
for passing our tokens so this will be
the method pass
and this method will compute an
expression now remember how we talked
about non-terminals and the different
types of non-terminals that we have we
have the expression we have the term we
have the factor so these are three
non-terminals and we're going to create
three different methods to define the
grammar rules for each of these
non-terminals so we're going to first of
all return
self dot expression
this is like the highest non-terminal we
want to compute the expression
and over here I'm going to Define first
of all let's define the factor
non-terminal the factor non-terminal is
pretty simple we're gonna check if the
token type is of integer or float so I'm
going to say if self dot token DOT type
is integer or if it's float
in that case I'm just going to return
the current token so let's say the
current token is the number five the
factor will check if the number 5 is an
integer which it is so then it's going
to just return the current token and
that is the factor now the term is
slightly complicated
remember how we defined a term to be a
factor multiplied or divided by another
Factor zero or more times
so I'm gonna first say the left node of
this term because right now let's say
the term is
okay let's just take an example 1
multiplied by two over here
we'll have 1 as the left node
multiplication is 0 node and two so this
is our list so the last representation
of this will be one comma multiplication
comma 2 and this is the term that we're
talking about
now how do we construct this term first
of all we need to extract the left
factors I'm going to say left underscore
node is equal to self dot Factor
then we're gonna move
and then we're gonna say as of now I'm
going to assume that there's only one
multiplication there's only one operator
but as you know the factors can be
multiplied or divided by each other zero
or more times so it doesn't necessarily
have to be one so I'm gonna say self-top
move so zero more times so the term
could just as well be a factor itself so
I'm gonna first of all say output
equals left underscore node in the case
where there is only the out there is
only one node and they are not
multiplied to another Factor zero more
times so it's just a factor itself in
that case the output will just be the
factor but in this situation where the
operation
value is equal to multiplication or
division
in this situation where the operation is
multiplication or division the output
won't just be equal to the factor rather
the output will be equal to first of all
we need to save the operations I'm going
to say operation equals self dot token
then I'm gonna move self dot move
then I'm going to say right unless
control is equal to self dot Factor
again
and in this case now the output will be
equal to this list so how we construct
the output it'll be left node operation
right node so I'm going to say output
equals left node
operation
right node
and now let's return the output
so I hope that makes sense
in the case where the term is equal to a
factor there are no multiplication or
divisions in that case we'll just return
output as the factor but in this
situation where there is multiplication
division in between the operands in that
case I'm going to make output equal to
the left node
left node multiplication which is
whatever the operation is multiplication
or Division and right ornament and then
we're going to return the output and
I'll remind you we're not talking about
multiple operations so this cannot
handle stuff like 1 times 2 times 3 it
can only handle a simple expression like
1 times 2 where there are two operands
and one operator now let's do the same
thing for the
expression
and in fact I'm just going to copy this
code because it's pretty simple too it's
pretty similar to the same code
and in fact one more thing I forgot to
do was to move after the right node and
why am I doing this so when I call
self.t term in line 25 instead of self
dot factor in the expression the left
node will be self dot term I don't need
to move after this so I'm just going to
remove that self.move method that I'm
going to call over there
in fact I can do the same thing over
here
I'm going to do self dot move
or or rather let's just leave it like
this so whenever you're calling a factor
you have to move after that because all
of the factors return the token
but whenever you're calling a term you
don't need to call self.move because it
is all self-doubt move is already called
in line 19 after the right node so we
don't need to call search dot move in
this situation
so that's it that should work now I as I
just need to change this to plus or
minus
and let me save this and I'm gonna do
I'm gonna run shell.py
so let's run it
let's do something like one plus two
multiplied by four
and okay I have to call the passer first
false I'm going to import
so there we go let's run it again
1 plus 2 multiplied by 4 and okay we I
think I made a small mistake over here I
forgot to change this to self dot term
so let me save now
and
run it again hopefully it works this
time one plus two multiplied by three
less to 3 and in this case you see we do
get this list
so how does this work let's just go
through it left node equals self dot
term in this case the term is just equal
to a factor because there is no
multiplication or division following it
so then the term is just equal to the
factor one and that's what we store as
the left node
then we check for additional subtraction
which is the case then we move to the
operation store the operation and then
we saw the right node is self dot term
and this time when we compute the term
there is multiplicational division and
that's why the term returns a nested
list so this works perfectly fine this
is in fact how our binary tree will look
like even if we do one multiply by two
plus four the this is the exact this is
exactly how the binary tree will look
like when we convert the python list to
the binary tree but we haven't solved
one problem which is multiple operations
as of now we're only checking if there's
one Opera if there's one operation plus
but let's say we do one plus two plus
three you see we have a problem it's not
giving the appropriate output so how do
we solve this I'm going to make two
changes first of all I'm gonna run a
while loop
I'm going to continuously check if
there's addition or subtraction and I'm
going to continue continuous
continuously check if there's
multiplication or division
so those are the two changes two changes
I'm going to make and one final change
I'm gonna make and I'll explain what
this means in just a second
is I'm gonna do left node
equals the following list and I'm gonna
return let node
I'm going to do the same thing over here
I'm going to return left node and get
rid of this output business
and make left not equal to that so let's
quit and run again and I'll explain what
this means in just a second
so 1 plus 2 plus 3
you see we get 1 comma two plus three if
I do one plus two plus three plus four
we get the following output now how did
this work so effectively by iteratively
changing the value of left node every
single iteration of the while loop we're
changing the value of left node and
we're assigning it the previous value
but by doing that we're effectively
pushing down the left node of the tree
so
let me construct the tree and show you
how it looks like
so this is how our tree looks like and
by continuously updating the left node's
value and assigning it what the previous
subtree was
so by continuously assigning this let's
go through this one time
so let's try one plus two plus three
and in this case we get the left node as
self dot term
and search for a term over here is just
the number one and then we run a while
loop to see okay we each time we look
for a plus symbol we store the operation
we move and then we get the right node
as self dot term again so this is one
plus two is the
um is the list over here left node
operation right node but we assign that
value to the left node so essentially
that list itself becomes the left node
and then plus and then the number three
and by doing this iteratively for all of
and by going down the left node every
single time by reassigning the left node
we are creating the right tree as you
saw over here so that's the basic
process we are to summarize again we are
on in every iteration we are updating
the value of the left node and we are
assigning it the previous left node
operation and right node so what we
previously had like over here what we
previously had was one comma plus comma
two so whatever we previously had we
assigned that to the left node itself
followed by plus followed by three so
that's the process we used to accept
multiple additions so that we can say
okay now of an expression is equal to a
factor
added or subtracted by another Factor
zero or more times now we've dealt with
that zero more times aspect to it so
that's the basic uh summary of passing
stage and now let's move on to the next
section where once we have created the
tree we'll have to Traverse to the
through the tree so we'll have to do
Post order traversal and follow that and
more I'll see you in the next section
so before we move on to the
interpretation stage I made a few
changes to our Alexa code instead of
storing the tokens and the token types
in the elixir of UI file I thought that
would be better to store it as though as
its own external file over here and
that's the same same code except for the
fact that in the representation method
we return it as a string because the
repr and there's also another method
called string def unders underscore
string
self and they are pretty similar they
have a few minute differences which I'm
not going to go into but they're pretty
similar in nature and so these both of
these methods return output as only in
string format they don't return integers
or floating Point numbers so it's better
if we clarify that over here and return
it as a string itself although in the
lexical analysis stage we did implicitly
Define the number as a string and then
pass a string over here uh it's just
going to explicitly Define
the output to be of type string so after
that change let's move on to The
Interpreter of py file where we will be
creating our interpreter so over here
I'm going to create The Interpreter the
init method
and this is going to take the tree as
its input
just like how the parser took the tokens
as its input now The Interpreter will
take the tree as its input so after that
I'm going to create a method called
interpret
and the interpret method is responsible
for computing our arithmetic expression
so as of now I have not talked about
brackets how you can compute expressions
like
OnePlus 2 in Brackets multiply by three
now we haven't talked about these we'll
talk about that in the next section
but as of now we can we should be able
to compute expressions like one plus one
or 15
minus 6 multiplied by 5 whatever we
should be able to compute expressions
like this after the interpretation stage
so in The Interpreter we'll have to do
Post audit reversal now if you remember
how the tree representation looked like
let's say for an input 1 plus 2
multiplied by 5 the tree representation
would look something like this you'll
have one over here you'll have plus and
then you'll have a nested list to
multiply by
fine so that's how our
uh our nested list how that's how the
parser creates the creates a
representation of the tree
and we have to now interpret this we
have to Traverse through this tree and
how are we going to Traverse it using
the post audit reversal method and if
you recall post order traversal refers
to the fact that you have to Traverse
through the left subtree then the right
sub tree and then after that if the
Traverse you have to go to the root node
now let's for a second assume there are
no sub trees and let's just read the
binary tree with two levels so there'll
be only two levels here there will be a
root node let's say a
and then there'll be B over here
and see over here so let's just treat it
it should be here
that's better
doesn't seem right
yeah there we go so that's let's just
assume that the tree is pretty simple it
has two levels and there are no subtrees
in such a situation how will we
interpret it so an example of an
expression like this would be
one plus one or five plus six or some
five plus six or something like that so
how can we interpret such a simple
binary tree so first of all we have to
go through the left node then the right
node and then the root node so to do
that
in post order traversal form we'll have
to first go through the left node so
left node
and in our tree let's say we have the
expression one plus one
the tree would look something like this
so the left node will be surf.3 the
zeroth index so the first position over
here that's the left node
the right node is equal to self Dot 3 2
so we are traversing through the left
node then the right node and finally
we'll go to the root node and we'll
compute the root node by adding the left
and right nodes so let's say the
operator
is equal to self dot three one
and over here we can return compute
binary this will have to create a
function for this and self compute
binary so given the left node right now
and operator we this function will
calculate then the output and return it
so here we'll give a left node operator
right now
so
this is the left subtree
and a sub tree which contains only one
node as of now this is the right subtree
and this is the root node
so that's our post order traversal now
let's create the method compute binary
so we'll take in the left node so left
up and right
now remember we can't do the following
so if
this is how it will typically look like
so we'll say if the operation dot value
is equal to addition
then return left plus right so
this is one way of doing it but it will
be wrong because right now the left
token is a string it's not even if we do
left dot value over here
and write dot value
these token values are stored as strings
remember over here we store the number
as a string and then we stored the data
type which is integer we in that we
passed a string number so we can't
perform this operation right now in fact
we have to convert the left or right
values into whatever that data type is
like for instance
if it's if if the expression is one plus
one let's say so when given the
expression one plus one the first token
will have a value of 1 and a data type
of integer so then we have to convert
from a string to an integer we need to
convert that value from a string to an
integer so one way we could do this is
we can say okay
if
left dot value left or type
is equal to integer
left equals int left
L if left to type
is equal to float
left equals float left
and then over here let's do if
try to type
is equal to end same thing
and you you'll see now that this is
pretty inefficient and will come up with
a better solution but just to illustrate
my point
that's uh now let's go along with this
if you write the type
okay so after all of that mess and it's
really disturbing to see to the eye but
anyway
after all of that mess
let's do if operation
dot value is equal to
Plus
then I want to return
left
right
and let's just handle this one now so
I'm going to save this
and let's let's close this over here
I'm going to delete this itself
now I'm going to call The Interpreter so
I'm going to say interpreter is equal to
interpreter
this will take in the tree
and this should be small
so interpreter
dot interpret
so then I'm going to say result is equal
to that
and let's print this result
I'll save I'll click on run and let's do
one plus one
okay we get an error
all right so this should have been
left dot value and not left so left up
value write dot value I am purposely
doing this to show how inefficient this
way is
no I don't value okay here we go one
more time
one plus one and
that seems to be a problem
okay this has to be LF okay my bad let's
run this one more time and hopefully it
works again
one plus one okay we get two perfect
let's try five plus three we get eight
but again this is a very in very
inefficient way of doing this problem so
how can we solve this issue where we all
our task at hand is to extract the type
of the of the of the data of the token
and then depending on the type whether
it's Intel whether it's float using that
type we convert it to its necessary data
integer or float so how can we
accomplish this task
so the first thing we need to do is we
need to extract the type so I'm gonna
say left
underscore type is equal to left DOT
type and right underscore type is equal
to right DOT type okay so now we've
extracted both types what next so there
is a function in Python called get
attribute and to show you how this works
I need to create two methods before and
then you'll understand how this works so
let's say the first method is read
underscore int and just bear with me for
a second when I do this
and it will take in a value
and this will return the integer of that
value
and they'll be refine read underscore
float
and it will return
floating point value
so there is a method there's a function
in Python known as get attribute
and we are essentially trying to find a
method within the self instance the name
of the method is the second parameter
what's the name of the method
it's equal to read it starts off with
read then there's an underscore but now
we don't know what the latter part of it
is
I'm gonna say the latter part of it is
equal to left underscore type
and I'm going to call it and it seems
like a lot but it's actually not not
that much
okay so what does this mean so over here
I'm saying okay now left is equal to
read underscore left underscore type so
if left DOT type is let's say integer
it will find the method read underscore
int and it will call that method by
giving the value of the token as a
parameter over here so okay let's let's
not complicated first over here so now
I'm gonna say get attribute within this
instance find the method read underscore
left underscore type so left under Skype
underscore type is equal to integer so
find a method called read int within
self and once you've found that method
call that method and the parameter which
is value with as passing the value left
dot value
so pass the value of let left as a
parameter to the read underscore int
method of the read underscore float
method depending on what the data type
of left is and I'm going to do the same
thing for the right as well so get
attribute self
read underscore
and over here we're going to do right
type
and the parameter I'm going to pass is
the value of write so write dot value
so there we go let's save this and I'm
going to try and run to see if it works
one plus one we get to same output but
it's much more easier to look at and
much efficient much more efficient code
so now with that sorted out we have to
again look at the interpret method
because we have still have to figure out
sub trees now if I do something like 1
plus 2 plus 3 you see this will start
giving errors because we haven't found a
way to deal with subtrees so let's
remember now let's consider a sub tree
over here an expression which has a sub
tree
so 1 plus 2 plus 3 what is the list how
will that list look like so let's create
it so there will be one plus two
and then after that plus three so that's
how the list step presentation of this
of the binary tree will look like one
plus two plus three so that's the
representation so until now we were
thinking we were assuming that every
single node will be just that will be a
node there won't be any subtree but now
a node can be the value the node can be
a sub tree as well so how do we deal
with such situations
the first thing we need to know is that
if it is a sub tree it will be it'll
have a type of list notice that this is
not a subtree this node is not a sub
tree and that's why it has a type of
integer but this node over here is a sub
list so we need to First detect whether
a tree whether a node is a subtree or
not so to do that
let's first do it for the left node and
I'm going to say if
is instance
I'm checking if the left node is an
instance of the inbuilt class in Python
the instance of the class list
so if it is an instance of the class
list then we know that we need to
compute this nested list as well and to
do that I'm going to use recursion
so how are you how are you going to do
it I'm going to say left underscore node
is equal to self dot interpret calling
this method itself
and the parameter I'm going to pass is
this nested list so I'm going to pass
this nested list
to the interpret method and it will
treat this as its own separate tree it's
going to compute it and that value will
be stored in left node and if there is
multiple subtrees it will go recursively
down this process is known as recursive
descent parsing by the way
and it's gonna for every single time we
have a new sub tree within a sub tree
it's gonna go to each subtree compute it
and eventually it's gonna come to this
higher level this topmost node which
with an interpreted value so once we
interpret left node we need to do the
same thing with the right node so I'm
gonna say if
is instance
right node of a list if it is a list
then I'm going to say write node is
equal to self dot interpret
right
so there we go those are our two
evaluations and now we can deal with
subtree so I'm going to say
evaluating less sub tree
and this is evaluating
write subtree
so we're done with both instances over
here and this is finally the root node
operation
so with that done
it's time to run our code let's see if
we run our code what output we will get
but actually before that we need to also
modify our compute bin method because as
of now it's only having handling
addition so we need to manipulate that
as well
so I'm gonna do L if
op dot value
equals minus
return left minus right
and if and in fact are not going to do
return I'm going to store this is an
output because this is an intermediate
representation we still have one more uh
one one more piece
remaining so instead in fact I'm just
going to store this as the variable
output so I'm going to say output equals
this
left plus right output equals left minus
right
LF op.value is multiplication I'm going
to say output equals left multiplied by
right
and finally LF
op.value is division
I'm going to say output equals left
divided by right
so and we're going to return output over
here not not just yet let's let's keep
this for now
so I actually figured that'd be one
problem over here notice that the
interpret method is not accepting a
parameter it's using the original
self.tree as a default tree to work with
but we don't want to do that in cases
when there is recursion I want to pass
in my own custom treat which is the
subtree and I want the interpret method
to process that subtree to process that
nested list so how can we do that so I'm
gonna come up with a efficient way to do
this so instead of passing in
the tree in the interpret method which
is one way you could solve this problem
rather I'm going to create a variable
called 3 equals none and what this means
is to say that if and if The Interpreter
method does not get a parameter it's
okay it's not going to throw an error
it's just going to set the tree
parameter to none and that's the first
case over here when we don't
provide a parameter so in the case where
it is none if tree is equal to none
3 is none in this case I want to make
self.tree
tree equals self.3
so if it is none we're going to make 3
equals self.3 and we'll be working with
only the tree we won't be working
directly with self.tree
let's remove that as well
but in the case when it's not none like
this situation where we are providing
our own custom uh tree over here
in the but in this situation when we are
providing our own custom tree over here
like left node and right node in these
two situations it will be using the tree
parameter that will be passed in line 36
and line 41. so I'm going to save this
and now let's go back to the compute bin
method
so in this scenario I don't want to
return the output as a default python
integer or a floating Point number
instead I want to return it as my own
class I want to return the integer
floater operation because that's the
point of having our own data classes so
how can we do that now if the output if
left or right are both type of integers
then the output will definitely be an
integer but even if one of them are a
floating Point number then the output
will be a floating Point number like for
instance if left is equal to 2.5 and
right is equal to 2 the output will be a
float if left is equal to 2 and right is
equal to 2 the output will be an integer
and let's say if left is equal to 2.5
and right is equal to 2.5 the output
will still be a float so if if even if
one uh even if one of these numbers is a
floating Point number the output will be
floating Point else it will be an
integer so for this I am going to say
return
integer
and see this is where separating the
data as its own custom file makes sense
because now I can import from this file
itself so I'm going to say from
tokens
import integer and float
so
return the integer value
of output
if
left DOT type left underscore type let's
deal with those
left underscore type and right
underscore type
um let's say left under the sky is equal
to integer
and right underscore type is equal to
integer if both are integer return the
output as in the format of integer else
return the output is a float
so now hopefully this works we have the
compute bin method written up we have
the interpret method written up using
post order traversal and if I run this
entire
let's see if it works so if I do let's
start off simple let's do one plus one
we get two
let's try 1 plus 2 we get three
one plus two plus three we should get
six
which we do let's try
one plus three times two
and over here it'll be 1 plus 6 rather
than 4 times 2 it'll be one plus six so
that should be 7 which we do get and I'm
gonna try floating Point numbers 2.5
into 2 we get 5.0 notice that even if
one of the numbers is floating point the
output is printed as a floating Point
number so there we go our entire
function is working I'll do one more
test to see if it's working and again
the output is floating point so our
interpreters working and for the first
time we have a running program that can
compute arithmetic or uh Expressions as
an input so this is a huge step now
because we have our basic Foundation
laid out and after this things get very
easy all we have to do is write down our
grammar rules compute make modifications
to the Alexa the parser and The
Interpreter I removed the password yeah
so all we have to do is make changes to
the Alexa interpret return passer and we
should be able to work with variables if
statements and all of that so in the
next section we're going to compute
variables so of all of that interesting
stuff I'll see you in the next section
so click quickly before we move on to
variables I also need to talk about left
brackings and writing brackets and how
we can use them to change our order of
operations so over here in the
operations I'm gonna also add in the
pair of parentheses which are valid
Expressions which are valid tokens as
well
oops
all right there we go so which have
added tokens as well so now let's go to
the parser
and over here
how will the camera look like the
grammar rule will be changed just a bit
remember when we said that the factor
is
um we set up was just an integer
zero one or two whatever it's just an
integer well now it can also be a left
bracket and a right bracket followed by
an expression inside
so
uh and then these brackets you know can
contain expression so to extract the
expression we can use the Expression
method now so over here I'm going to say
l if self dot token that value is equal
to the Open Bracket Open Bracket
and in this case
I am going to say surf dot move to move
to the next token because the open
record is not very useful we move to the
next token which is the start of the
expression then I'm going to say
expression equals self dot expression
now we have extracted the expression
and with that with that extraction now
we can return the expression
so if I save and now let's go to the
Shell and I'm going to run this file
1 plus 2 multiplied by 3 gives you 7 but
if I now enclose this with a pair of
parentheses you see we get one plus two
plus three one plus two times three
equals nine
and we can even deal with uh multiple
parentheses over here so if I have let's
say
1 plus 2
multiply by 4 divided by 6 we get 2.0
so now finally we are going to be able
to work with variables assigning
variables and again as usual now we're
going to use the same pattern we're
going to start off with Alexa update the
Alexa update the password and then
finally update The Interpreter so to do
this I'm gonna first talk about the
grammar rules that that are involved the
first grammar rule involved is in in
terms of the variable is the fact that
the Declaration is going to be made by
the keyword make so like in stuff like
JavaScript you have let you have VAR in
Python you don't have a declaration as
such but in our programming language
Shadow script the Declaration will be
make so it's going to be make and then
the variable name
and then that's gonna equal something
let's say 50. so that's going to be our
grammar rule for creating a variable so
we're going to start off with make so
for that we need to to accept these uh
text based inputs we need to accept
letters so for that we need to First
create a constant over here to check if
there is a letter or not
letter so
so with that we have defined the letters
now let's go ahead and uh in the
tokenize method I'm going to say l if
the current character is in Lexa dot
letters
so in this case that there are two
possibilities the first possibility is
that the letter makes up the Declaration
the second possibility is that the
letter makes up the variable name so
over here
we need to ensure that we
take care of both situations so I'm
gonna say first of all we need to
extract the entire board be it be the
Declaration be the variable name so just
like how we had to extract number method
I'm gonna run an extract word from uh
method over here so I'm going to say
word is equal to self dot extract
underscore word
and let's create that method just below
the extract number method so over here
I'm going to say extract underscore
method extract unscope word
and over here I'm gonna say the word is
equal to an empty string for now
while the current character
is in lexa.letters
same thing as before
and the current index is less than the
length of the text
in in these two situations
if both are true then I'm going to say
word
plus equals the current character and
then we're going to move to the next
character
and at the end I'm going to return the
word itself
so over here we have extracted the word
and after that we have to check if it is
part of the Declaration so let's create
a list
for declarations I'm going to say
declarations as of now it's just going
to be one item the make declaration but
if we intend to have multiple
declarations like in JavaScript you have
let you have var2 declarations so if you
have multiple of these uh maybe when
then we have to update this list so for
now let's keep it as a list
and then I'm gonna say
if word
in declarations
or Alexa dot declarations
in this case I'm gonna set the token
type to a declaration so I'm going to
create that data type over here in the
tokens.py file
I'm going to copy this init method
and the
the name of the type will be decl
standing for declaration
so now I'm gonna say self dot token
is equal to declaration
and we'll pass the word as the
Declaration and that's import this
in our extra PMI file one more thing we
need to import is the variable class and
let's create that as well be
the same as our previous classes
and over here I'm gonna create variable
and the name of this data type will be
VAR standing for variable
so now that we've imported the variable
and we can move on to the next uh
situation in the case when it's not in
the Declaration so else I'm gonna say
self dot token is equal to variable
and now we have the token stored so I'm
not going to run the rest of the stuff
let's just print the tokens to see what
we get
so if I print tokens
and one more thing minitro is is we need
to handle equal signs so over here we
have the equal symbol so that is another
operation that I have added over here
so now let's run the file let's run
shell.py and I'm gonna write make a
equals 50.
and you see we get the Declaration make
a equals 50 the tokenization process
works just fine
so now I'm gonna go back to the Alexa I
think we're pretty much done with the
tokenization process now let's go ahead
to the passer where things get a little
bit complicated
now we need to
um okay let's go to the passer now so
to handle the uh to handle the variable
assignment part how can we handle this
so we need to create a new method I told
you for every grammar rule we'll be
creating a new method and now I'll be
creating the grammar rule for a
statement now variable assignment is a
statement it's a type of statement there
will be other types of statements like
if statements while Loops there are
different types of statements but one
type of statement is the variable
assignment so how can you handle these
variable assignments so for that I'm
going to create a method called
statement
if the first token so if self dot token
DOT type is equal to declaration
then this will be a variable assignment
statement
but if the self.tok token DOT type
is equal to integer or if it's equal to
float
or if is equal to
operation like for instance we can have
the left brackets so if it's equal to
operation in these situations in these
three situations
I'm gonna set the statement type to be
equal to arithmetic expression
so now in this situation you have a
arithmetic expression in this situation
you have variable assignment
so
the first thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to call statement
like so
now over here in the Declaration I'm
gonna one once we know that it is a
declaration I'm going to move to the
next token next token will be the
variable name and to extract the
variable name I'm just gonna create a
new method called variable so I'm going
to say left underscore node is equal to
self dot variable and in fact we can
create a binary tree of this as well so
how will the binary tree of make a
equals 50 look like it looks something
like this so we have the equals operator
and then we have
uh we have
that connection
and then a
and let's do
50 over here so that's the binary tree
of a make a equal 50. so now left node
is equal to variable name so self dot
variable will extract the variable name
then we have to move after that
and then the operation
we have to check if
self dot token DOT type is equal to
operation or let's just say
if the value is equal to equals
in this case I'm going to save the token
so I'm going to say operation equals
self dot token
and over here finally I'm going to after
we save the operation I'm going to say
self. move move to the next token and
then the next token can be any
expression it can be an arithmetic
expression it can be just 50 or it can
be 5 plus 7 minus 3 multiply by 4 so we
need to extract that expression so I'm
gonna say right underscore node
is equal to self dot expression
so finally I'm just going to return the
list
left underscore node operation
so now we've extracted the statement and
if it's not an assignment statement and
this is going to do
self return self dot expression
so let's save
and I'm going to delete and I'm gonna
run the parser now just see how the
passer looks looks like
so if I save this and let's just run it
to see if we get any errors first of all
make
a equals 12.
and we don't get narrow okay we haven't
defined the variable let's just Define
that really quick
so here the variable method
all it will do is it will first move
because right now
um over here declaration okay so we have
already moved from the Declaration and
now the variable method will check for
the it will extract the token so it's
going to say if the self.token DOT type
is equal to VAR that means if it's a
type of variable
in that case we're just gonna return the
self dot token
so now let's check this if I clear and
run again
make a equals 12 you don't get any error
you know the tokenization has worked
perfectly now if I print the tree
you'll see what I meant by when I said
order of Precedence the
um how we computed and all about the
trees and when I talked about
putting the expression it's been in a
nested list in uh and the Declaration in
an outer list so that's how it looked
like so if I run this now and I say make
a equals 50.
and I run it you see we get a equals 50
over here
and for now you can't see it but let's
do make a equals 1 plus 2 multiplied by
5 you see now this expression is in a
nested list it has higher precedence
it's computed first and then after that
the assignment works because we don't
want to make a equal one and then
compute we don't want to make a equal
one and then compute the rest of that
expression that makes no sense we want
to compute the entire expression and
then whatever the answer of that is we
want to assign that value to the
variable a so now we've modified the
passer we have modified the Alexa and I
hope that makes sense now let's go on to
The Interpreter where we will be storing
the variables in a dictionary so as of
now we can compute basic arithmetic
expressions and we have also deal with
the code delt we've also dealt with the
code regarding the tokenization and the
parsing so let's say I create a variable
and I will make a equals 5 so as you can
see the parser and the tokenizer are
working fine if I do make a equals
something like 7 minus 2 then it knows
that it has to encapsulate seven and two
into its own nested list so we've dealt
with the parser and the tokenizer now
it's time to move to the interpreter but
I realized just a few problems with our
current code and I'm gonna fix them
right now the first problem I noticed is
that in the Alexa we are storing the
variable and we're giving it only one
value but in the tokens the type of the
variable is just bar so effectively
we're not specifying the data type so
say for instance it's a variable with
data type of integer so it's let's say
we make the statement make a equals five
so then the data type is integer and the
value is 5 but in this case the data
type we've kept it as VAR which is
stands for variable and the valuable
started as the variable's name so that's
problematic we need to store three
things over here we need to store first
of all the variable name
second of all the fact that it is a
variable so R and third of all we need
to store its data type
now as of now like for instance let's
take the example make a equals five we
have not uh computed the expression over
here so we don't know what the data type
is it could be a float it could be a
integer so we don't know what the data
type is so initially what we have to do
is set it as an empty data type and I'm
going to do that using a question mark
so how am I going to represent data type
and variable well I'm going to say
VAR
and then I'm going to give a pair of
parentheses and I'm going to give a
question mark because we don't know the
date of my data type as of now so this
is what we're going to set the data type
to as of now but later on in the
interpretation stage when we have
computed the value when we've computed
this expression we're going to replace
that question mark with the actual data
type so that's the first change I want
to make and over here let's go to
the Alexa
and yeah so so that was the only change
I had to make so now the Alexa over here
it will create variable from the word
and in the tokens dot py file it'll
it'll give the date time with VAR
followed by a question mark over here
now with that done let's move on to the
next step now since we have changed our
variable over here in the tokens we've
created the type
in such a manner we've changed it we
cannot be checking for self.token.type
to be equal to variables instead what we
can check for is if it starts with the
three letters VAR
so we can use the starts with method
which is an inbuilt method for strings
in Python and this will check if the
string starts with the three characters
V A and R so similarly I just find the
other instances where we have created VR
and as you can see over here
another instance so I'm gonna instead of
making it equal I'm going to check if it
starts with
the variable
and that's it so now that we've done
this and now that we've changed the
tokens.py file and updated the
interdependencies it's time to move on
to another file which is called the
data.py file now the data.py file will
be storing all of the variables in a
class so this class will contain a
dictionary and this dictionary will be
keeping track of all the variables and
their corresponding values so for that
we need to go to the shell.pify file and
we need to create or we need to create
an instance of the data.priva file
before the while loop we can't keep it
in the while loop because if we keep the
instance in the while loop the data
would refresh every single time we get a
new input but rather than doing that we
want to keep track of the previous
inputs as well so here I'm gonna say
from data import the class data and I'll
create it in just a second
and over here I'm going to say base
equals data so we're creating an
instance of that data so I'm going to
create class data
and set the init method
like so itself and we won't be taking
any properties the only thing I want to
run the first time the instance is
created is I want to create the
variables dictionary and set it to an
empty dictionary
so let's save that and the base is also
set now I'm going to uncomment The
Interpreter and pass the base as an
input to The Interpreter
so now The Interpreter can deal with all
of the data so it can write to the
dictionary when when like the action
over here initially was with addition
and subtraction the action was to add
two numbers but in this time we have to
deal with memory we'll have to add to
the dictionary we have to interact with
the dictionary and for that we need
access to the base variable and that's
why we're going to accept that base
variable over here
and we're going to interact with the
base variable we're going to interact
with the dictionary add variables to the
dictionary change the values of
variables to the dictionary and read
from the dictionary so I'm going to say
self.data is equal to base
so that's it in terms of The Interpreter
now let's go ahead and write the code
for the data.py file so variable dot
value refers to the variable name and
now let's go ahead and refer now let's
go ahead and save the data to the
server.variables dictionary so I'm going
to say surf top variables
and in this the variable name is going
to be the key and the value is just
going to be the expression
so that's what we've done we're done
with the right method and now we're done
with the data class itself it's time to
move to The Interpreter where we have to
save our data and sometimes you want to
retrieve the data like for instance so
we have two tasks now the first task
is to save data like for instance if we
have an expression make a equals 5 we
need to save the value of a into this
data dictionary and the second task is
if we have it say another expression
make D equal a plus one in an expression
we need to be able to
parse we need to be able to understand
the value of a variable so in the past
of py file we have to update our grammar
to say that even if the even if the the
gram we have to update the grammar in
such a way that thing that a factor can
be an integer it can be a float it can
be an expression within a pair of
parentheses also it can be a variable
itself so it can start with the variable
itself so that's the only chain I've
changed I've made to the past of py file
and I've written self dot token if it is
a variable so this will just return the
current token corresponding to the
variable so that's it in the pastor py
file and
now we need to work with the
interpreter.py file modify it so that we
can be able to create new variables and
read from the data py file when
necessary uh during this expression
during Computing during the compilation
of such expressions
so for all of that and more I'll see you
in the next section so now in The
Interpreter of py file I'm gonna treat
the equal symbol similar to a binary
operation there's a left part and the
right part and we have to do some action
with the operation the action being we
have to set the left hand side equal to
the right hand side and we have to save
the data in the data.py file so how are
we going to do this we can't make an
alif and put it over here because we'll
have we'll face problems in line 22 and
23 because they are reading the data as
Floats or integers but now these are
variables so before we hit line 22 and
23 we have to compute the variable
assignment so over here I'm going to say
if the operation of value
is equal to an equal symbol now in this
case what I'm going to do is I'm finally
going to update the in in over here I'm
going to replace the question mark with
the actual data type
notice that the right type is already
computed we've already computed the type
of the right hand side which is the
expression so once you've computed the
expression like for instance let's see
the expression is
make a equals 5 the right hand side is
the expression the type of that is
already computed in right DOT type and
in right underscore type stores that in
a string format so over here instead of
the first thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to update the variables type so
how am I going to do this I'm going to
say left DOT type
remember left refers to the variable
itself the token for the variable so I'm
going to say left DOT type
referring to here so left DOT type
I'm going to update that left or type
and I'm going to update that to equal
VAR and then within the pair of
parentheses I'm going to put in the the
type of the right hand side which is the
expression so if the expression is an
integer is a type of an integer the type
of the variable will also be integer so
over here I'm going to set it to right
underscore type
so there we go that's the first thing
I'm going to do I'm going to update the
left DOT type and the next thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to write to the
data.py file so how I'm going to write
it I'm going to say self dot data dot
right
and remember we had two parameters the
variable and the expression so the
variable will just have to pass it as is
so the variable token and the expression
I'm just going to pass that as is as
well so the expression will also have a
type of a token because remember
in Computing a binary we return so
because these expressions are sub list
so even they have to be computed first
and in computation of a binary we return
an integer or a float and therefore even
the right
even the right expression is not just a
number it is a type of token either of
integer or either a float so that's it
we're gonna write the data to served to
the dictionary
in the data class and once we're done
with that I am going to test this so we
won't be we haven't completed task 2 yet
reading variables but we have we have
the ability to write two variables so
now let's see and just to see if it
works on I'm going to return something
so after we write
I'm going to return the read all so I'm
going to I want to see the updated
variables list updated variables
dictionary so to do that all I'm going
to do is I'm going to return
self.data dot read underscore all
so let's save it and I'm gonna go to
shell.py now
and I'm going to run this so if I do
make a
equals 5 there we go we have a
dictionary if I don't make b equals 10
that 2 will work this is the variable
name and this is not a number don't be
deceived by it that's just because we
have set the underscore representation
as a string of the value it's not a
number instead it is the token class
it's the instance of the token class
it's the instance of the integer or
float class
so that's how we can create new
variables now let's learn how we can
read new variables so that we can even
pass expressions like make b equal a
plus 1.
so to do that I'm going to go back to
our interpreter of py file
and remember we have made
the exception of variables as factors
we've coded that part in in the past wi
file so now let's go ahead and do SEC
part two let's handle challenge two in
an expression like a plus one where we
have to compute a variable we need to
create a new method to read from a
variable as of now in lines 27 and 28 we
can compute methods we can compute an
integer and a floating Point number
using these two methods which are
highlighted but we need to create a new
method for reading a variable so let's
read VAR
and self and this will take in the ID so
when we're calling it left dot value
corresponds to the variables name so ID
is what I'm referring to as the
variable's name
now the variable itself is equal to
self.data.read using this ID because in
this data.py file we assigned the
variable the way the variable name is
the key and the value we assigned it
will be the expression and the
expression is an instance of the
classes integer or float
so right now we have the variable
we have the variable
instance of integer offload now we need
to extract the type so in Integrity type
is n turn and floor T type is float so
we need to extract that so I'm going to
say variable underscore type is equal to
variable DOT type
so now we'll extract the type from that
token remember over here we saved the
token and the token could be integer
float Now using that value I am
extracting the type of the token whether
it's integer or whether it's float and
now from the read underscore VAR method
I'm going to call read underscore in and
read underscore float so over here I'm
gonna say get attribute from the self
itself I'm gonna say read
and I'm gonna input variable underscore
type as our variable in this string
inside of here so we're going to embed
variable underscore type in this string
over here
and so we need now we need to call it
and we'll call it using the variables
value itself
so what is the value of the variable
that is equal to variable
um it's over here it's not it's equal to
variable dot value
corresponds to whatever the expression
evaluates to type corresponds
so value corresponds to whatever the
expression evaluates to type corresponds
to the type of that expression whether
it's integer whether it's float
so that's it so now we have the get
attribute function we're calling the get
attribute function and from the get
attribute function we're calling the
read underscore in and read underscore
float methods now I'm just going to
return this
and hopefully this should work now so if
I save and just one more change I need
to do here just one more changes in
let's look at 933 and 34 left underscore
type in this case let's say it's a
variable over here so what will left
underscore type B equal to it'll be VAR
int it'll be equal to
VAR in
but the method's name is underscore VAR
it's not equal to VAR unders so how do
we handle the situation so I'm just
gonna say left type
we're going to make it equal to variable
the type will be equal to variable if
the string starts with
variable
so even if the type is this I'm going to
assign the even if type is VAR int I'm
going to assign the type to be equal to
VAR so that when we reach 934 and 33 and
34 rerunsco bar is called and not read
underscore brackets int so
this is what I'm going to do I'm going
to call I'm gonna make the typewr
instead of VAR end of our float whatever
if it starts with bar as it's just the
normal number and in that case I'm just
going to return the type
left DOT type
and similarly I'm going to copy this
paste it over here
we have to do right this time
and let's save and hopefully it works
this time so now I'm going to clear
everything
Let's test our program out so I'm gonna
run it
let's make a equal to 5
I'm going to make b equal to 10 and then
I'm going to make c equal to a plus b
and there we go C is equal to 15 and our
program is successfully working
so that's all about variables and next
up we're going to talk about unary
operators I left this thing out during
evaluation of arithmetic Expressions but
now we're going to talk about unary
operators so for all of that and more
I'll see you in the next section
so unary operators are simply operations
that occur on just one operand so an
operand is like a number so a binary
operation remember was 5 plus 2 that's
binary operation the first operand is
five second operand is two you have two
operands and one operations five plus
two is a binary operation a unary
operation is something like plus five or
it's something like minus five
since something like plus five or minus
five so to handle such Unity operations
to handle such Unity operations I'm
gonna change the factor a bit I'm going
to modify this Factor method a bit to
accept even an operation so a factor can
now be equal to an integer it can be
equal to an expression inside a pair of
parentheses it can be equal to a
variable it can also be equal to an
operation plus another integer so over
here I'm gonna do L if self dot token
dot value or let's do type DOT type
if it's equal to
op if it's an operation
uh what do you do in this scenario
in fact I'm not just going to do
operation I'm gonna
um because in the Lexus of py file we
defined even the equal the equal sign to
be an operation so rather than doing
that I'm just gonna use plus and minus
because those are the two possible
unitary operations you can have so here
if it's Plus or if self dot token type
is equal to minus in this scenario I'm
gonna first store the operation operator
equals self.token
then I'm gonna self dot move
and then I'm gonna do operand is equal
to self not Factor again
so if it's an integer it will just
return self.token and we get the operand
as let's say plus 5 plus will be the
operator and then operand will be safe
dot Factor will go back here and say 5
is an integer so we get 5 and plus 5
will be the operator plus operand now
finally I'm going to return an array
operator
operand
instead of using three items in one area
now we're gonna have only two this is a
unary operation the operator and the
operand and we need to handle this
special case in the interpret method
over here I'm gonna say
if
the if the tree is an instance of a list
first of all it has to be an instance of
list so I'm gonna say if tree is an
instance of a list and after that
and the length of the tree
is equal to 2 which means it's a unary
operation only the operator and the
operand
in that case what I'm going to do is I
am going to compute it now I'm going to
compute the unary operation I'm going to
say return self dot compute underscore
unary
and the operator
will be 3 0.
operand will be three one
so let's Define compute unary
this will take itself this will take in
left or operator
operand
and this should just return the operator
upon the operands of
it should just do operator or in fact
I'll I'll do it in this way I'm say if
operator
is equal to plus and this time you have
to still check for Value if operated at
Value is Plus
I'm gonna return
Plus operand
and we can't do operand here directly
because remember we still have to
configure
the the left and right the operand the
same in the same way we configured the
left and right values and so I'm going
to copy all of this over here
it can be equal to a variable as well
plus a for instance
so
it's just going to be for the operand
this time operand
is equal to variable
operand DOT type
and operand type again
so one final thing
I'm gonna read
operand again
yeah so yeah okay so let's do operand
and operand
so there we go now L if the operator
dot value
is minus
in that case I'm going to return minus
operate operand
so now let's run this function so I'm
gonna
say in this uh your return compute unary
so this should work and one more
exception is let's say we just input a
number like one or let's say we input a
number like two we can't handle that
right now because we are assuming there
is a valid binary operation there is an
operation but there is an exception
where the user just does not have any
operations just one number inputed in
that scenario I'm going to do L if
um let's say
L if
not is instance
of list if it's not even a tree in that
case I am just going to return
the tree
so if it's not a list like for instance
uh if there are if the only input is the
number one
the input is the number one
in that case our tree will look
something like this it'll just it'll
just look like the number one but
instead it's actually the integer class
so it's the integer class with type of
int and value one
so it won't be a list it'll just be this
one value over here so if it's not an
instance of a list that means the user
has just inputted the value one or the
value of two let's just input is the
number in that case I just want to
return that out because you don't have
any operation to do else if none of
these are true
we are going to do our usual binary
operation
so let's delete
and this is the urinary operation
and this is no operation
so let's save and I'm going to run the
shell
if I do plus five I get none this time
let's see where we went wrong let's
print the tree actually see if that's
working
plus five no even the tree is returning
none so there's a problem over here
itself
okay that's not tight that should be
value not type so that's my mistake
so I'm gonna close this again
run it I'm going to do plus five
okay and now we get a proper error this
time let's let's look at this look into
this one
okay so it turns out I made two mistakes
the first mistake is that I'd install
this as a type this is actually the type
not the operand itself
and I'm going to run type again and the
second mistake I made was in the parse
method I did not so this is value I
store this is type so I wrote
self.token.type instead of self.token
dot value so let's save now and
hopefully it works this time so if I run
again
class 5 we get the output is 5 let's do
minus five I get minus five I'm going to
make a equal to 10. and then I'm going
to do minus a and we get minus 10.
so that works now we've computed unary
operations and we've also handled the
scenario where we have no operation like
let's try no operation just the number
one we get one outputed so another proof
computed unary binary and no operations
were effectively done with arithmetic we
can do complicated arithmetic as well
and we can handle variables we can store
them we can read from them and now we've
covered most of the basics we have some
additional functionality to add but
it'll be really easy now since we have
the basic Foundation uh mapped out so
now let's move on to the next section
so in this section of the course we'll
be talking about compare comparison
operators and Boolean operators now
Boolean operators we've talked about
this way back in the start of the course
where we talked about logic gates and we
said that there are three main Boolean
operators as the and gate the or gate
and the not gate so in programming as
well you require these three
logic kits you require these three
operators you require these three
Boolean operators
to perform logical operations like for
instance I can find
an instance over here where we use the
logical operation in Python itself so it
only seems viable to it only seems
logical to give these operators to your
users who will be using our programming
language for them to for to allow them
to
create more useful and logical code so
that's about Boolean operators
comparison comparison operators and
stuff like greater than checking if two
numbers are greater than each other less
than greater than n equal to less than
equal to if two numbers are equally then
to each other so these are the sort of
checks that comparison operators do and
remember all of this write down in the
fundamental level is just a bunch of
logic gates operating and that's why I
had talked about logic gates in the
start of this course
so to manage these operators first I'm
going to talk about the Boolean operator
so we're going to first create
a list of Boolean operators I'm going to
say Boolean
Boolean operators let's just do Boolean
and over here we're gonna have ADD
the second one is r and these third one
is not
and after that I'm gonna go to the
tokenize method and over here
these are examples of words so in this
will come in the lecture dot letters
condition and we first check if it's a
declaration and if if it's not a
declaration then we're gonna We're Not
Gonna immediately assign it a variable
for which gun check if it is part of the
Boolean operator so I'm gonna say
and if
word in lecture or Boolean operators
lecture of Boolean
and then I'm going to set token equal to
class Boolean
and inputting the Boolean the name of
the Boolean operator let's create this
class Boolean
and I'm gonna call it I'm gonna I'm
sorry I'm gonna call the init method
inside
still taken self value
and super not underscore in it
Bool and value
so let's say that and let's import
Boolean
from the data types that we've stored
so after that now we're pretty much done
with the lexor now let's move on
to the passer
in the passer instead of calling the
expression method I'm going to call
another another method called Boolean
expression now what do the what is the
grammar rule for Boolean look like the
grammar rule will be like something like
this so we'll have Bool
expression and that will just be equal
to
a normal expression
and then the Boolean operator name let's
say and it can be or it can be not and
that's going to be in small case and or
not and followed by another expression
so two expressions followed by the
Boolean operator so to implement this
I'm gonna create a new method let's call
it Boolean expression
Boolean
underscore expression
self
so left underscore node
equals self dot expression
then while the current token same thing
over here and we're doing a lot of copy
pasting
so it seems logical now to assign this
same boilerplate code this uh basic code
as its own method and then we call that
method every single time instead of
rewriting all of this code
which kind of gets a bit messy now we've
already done it Thrice so now after I
create the Boolean expression and the
comparison operator expression I'll be
wrapping all of this code
highlighted over here I'll be wrapping
all of this code into its own new method
and we call that method using in the
Boolean expression in the normal
expression method in the term method and
so on so over here we're gonna call
self.expression and if the token type is
of Bool
that's it that's the only check in that
case the operation self.token and self
dot expression over here
so let's save and I'm gonna check if
this works in the parser itself so I'm
gonna comment Out The Interpreter okay
it's already commented out and I'm going
to run this
okay I'm gonna run the shell
if I run and now let's do
the Boolean operator five and six
you see that works
okay it's only it it did not work
um
so type Bool left underscore node is
self dot expression
so the token the it seems to be working
in the token the token seems to be
working well the problem comes in parse
okay that's because we haven't called
Bool unsca expression my bad so wherever
we have called expression now
self dot expression wherever we will
call that
we're gonna replace that with bold on
expression so over here
I'm going to say self dot Bool
underscore expression
so let's replace it
I think that's the name of our method
yes it is Boolean expression
so let's replace the first one
second one let it be like that third one
let it be like that and let's replace
this one as well
and this one as well
so there we go
I think okay there's one more remaining
so I think that's it I'm going to save
now
and I think it should work this time so
let's go to the Shell let's run
let's run again
and I'm gonna do five and two that works
let's say if I do
um five plus three
or seven plus six and these operations
don't mean anything as of now they only
make sense when combined with the
comparison operator so over here you see
we get 5 plus 3 or is the Boolean
operator seven plus six and notice I've
given this higher precedence sorry lower
precedence over the other operators I
want this to be done last
because that's how you do it you don't
want to do three or seven and then the
addition that doesn't make any sense you
wanna give this the lowest precedence so
now let's move on to the conditional
operators
so I'm going to say conditional or
whatever I keep saying conditional it's
comparison comparison
comparisons let's do comparisons and
then the first one will be greater than
next one will be less than
third one will be greater than and equal
to
fourth one will be less than or equal to
and to check if two things are equal and
python it's done as equal equal but in
our programming language it's going to
be question mark equal because I think
that makes more sense
we're checking if it's equal or not so
we use a question mark
so now we need to create another
variable special characters
and only if the character is in these
special characters do we check if it's
in the comparison comparisons list
so let me greater than less than equal
question mark so these are the four
possible special characters now let's go
over here and I'm gonna say l if
L if self dot character
dot special characters
in that case
I'm gonna make the
compare
comparison equal to an empty list for
now comparison operator let's do there
is an operator
and over here I'm going to say while
serve dot character is in Alexa dot
special characters
and self dot index is less than the
length of the text
in this case I'm gonna
add the current character and then I'm
going to move
and finally I'm gonna
token
is equal to this time it's not going to
be a Boolean it's going to be a
comparison it's a comparison
and we're going to feed In the
comparison operator here let's create
that as well
comparison
and I'm going to call this comp
is the data type
so let's import that finally comparison
save and hopefully it works now so
I'm gonna go back to the first of py
and remember where in Boolean expression
we called expression now we're going to
call comp expression the comparison
expression and comparison 2 is pretty
similar in a comparison components per
expression
that's just equal to
an expression
greater than or equal to less than or
equal to another expression you get the
idea all of the
comparative Expressions so we add a five
in front of each of them and all of them
together and followed by another
expression
so we are going to create one define com
underscore expression
so we'll take itself the left node will
be self dot expression
and now we need to change this to make
it com underscore expression and comp on
this expression
expression left dot equals F dot
expression and while
self dot token
DOT type is comp
same thing I'm going to copy this
and I'm going to do yeah that seems fine
lastly we need to return the left mode
so let's return left node
and over here instead of calling
expression I'm going to call comp
underscore expression
save it and let's try and running it
I'm going to file let's check if Phi is
equal to 5
and 7 greater than 2.
so it groups this first as expression
and groups the second expression and
checks and and adding the Boolean
operator between both of them
so for The Interpreter I created the
following code it's really messy but
essentially what I'm doing is the same
as what I did before if left is greater
than right I'm going to Output 1 which
stands for True else I'm going to Output
0 and I'm going to continue for this for
all of the binary operators except not
now not all there is a Boolean operator
is a unary operator because it does not
apply on two different operands it
applies on just one operand so to handle
not we have to form a different
mechanism over here so in the past the
py file I created not for the unary
operator
and I said okay this is how we made plus
M minus unary operators I'm going to
make not a unary operator and return the
operator and self the Boolean expression
just like how I did over here so because
you can also have an expression not just
a factor like for instance you can have
um not 5 equals five so the Expressions
5 equals 5 and not is the unary operator
and it actually turns out that even you
can have the same thing over here since
you're falling self tough factor I think
it'll be more wise to call Self the
Boolean expression over here itself
so there we go now we're done with the
parset of paper file and one more change
I did it was
I allowed for not
so as of now we only call Boolean
expression if it if the first token is
integer floater operation now even if
the first token is not like for instance
not Phi equals 5 so this is still an
arithmetic operation that I want to
calculate and therefore I go into self
dot Boolean expression so that's the two
changes I made to pass the p y now let's
go to The Interpreter and handle the not
keyword in The Interpreter so over here
it's a unary operation
but do not that I just realized this
that the in in the universe unary
operation the operand can be an
expression it doesn't necessarily have
to be an integer like for instance you
can have minus 5 times 5 this is a valid
expression as of now I only thought of
the possibility of maybe if minus five
but it's not necessarily the operand is
not necessarily an integer or a float it
can be an expression as well so to
handle that scenario I'm going to say
expression
equals
cell a tree one
I'm gonna say if expression is an
instance of list that means it has
a sub Tree in it so if expression is an
instance of a list then I'm going to say
expression equals self dot interpret
recursion again
expression
so now instead of passing in tree one
I'm gonna pass in expression itself
so I'm going to save this now and let's
go up to the compute unary method
and over here let's add one final unary
operator if operator dot value is not
then I'm going to return 1 if not
operand is true else I'm going to return
0. so let's save all of this let's go to
shell.py and I'm going to run this now
I'm gonna do not 5 equals 5 that means 5
equals 5 is once not 1 should be 0 and
that indeed is the output let's try
something else let's try Phi equals 5
and 7 greater than 2 that turns out to
be 0 yes because 5 is equal to 5 and 7
is greater than 2. if I do 5 equals 5
and 7 less than 2
we'll get 0 but if I do 5 equal to 5 and
7 or 7
less than 2 we should get 1 which we
indeed do so that's all about
conditional operators and Boolean
operators sorry comparison operators and
Boolean operators and we'll use these
two concepts to form our if statements
and finally in the end we'll run a while
loop as well so for all of that and more
I'll see you in the next section
so in this section the course I wrote
the code regarding the if statements now
before we go into it let's just talk
about syntax so the grammar rule will
look something like this we have an if
statement followed by an expression and
after that we can have L uh sorry the
keyword do so expression and if the
expression is true then do statement
so that's the rule for if statements and
also that can be if Alice statements as
well in this so you can have if these
statements not true then you have L if
another expression followed by do
another statement
and this can go on and on the alif
statements can go on and long and then
finally at the end you can have an else
statement followed by do and statement
so that's the way in which we're going
to create our if statement number I've
already written the code for the Alexa
and parser because this stuff is pretty
repetitive and I don't want to write it
all again so
over here I've created reserved keywords
as its own list now it has if alif else
and do and in the tokens.py file we've
also created a class for reserved tokens
now after that I went into the lecture
and apart from checking for Boolean
values and declare declarations I'm also
checking if the word is in the legs is
in the result list
in that case I'm going to add it to the
instance of a reserved class
now after that I'm going to go to the
passer the passer has three aspects to
it first of all in the statement method
we check if the token value is if
if it is if if it is if then we go to
self.if statements we run the self.if
statements method
and the self.if statements method runs
over here it stores the conditions and
actions in two arrays so the conditions
correspond
conditions correspond to these
expressions
stored in a list and statements
correspond actions correspond to these
statements stored in the list
so we store both of them as initially
they are empty and then we call if
statement make itself dot if statement
now we go to this method Self Storage if
statement which is responsible for
grabbing the one con grabbing one
condition and grabbing one action
pertaining pertaining to one if
statement or one alif statement
so it first of all moves from the if for
alif statement so it moves from the if
statement goes to the condition
and then it stores the condition as a
Boolean expression
then if these token dot value is due
as we saw over here
then we grab the statement we move up
from the do and then we grab the
statement and store it as an action and
we return it now this second elf
statement is for a special case when
when we have unary operations now when
we have unary operations and parentheses
we call Self the Boolean expression
within it and tend to move a point after
the do keyword
uh so we tend to move ahead of this so
this second statement
which is
over here the second statement checks
for if the the do keyboard is in the
previous token in that scenario we
return the condition and action
so that's the alif statement and we run
a while loop for all the LF statements
in the end we check for an else
statement we move from the else
statement we move from the to keyword
and then we we grab the action and store
it in a list of three items if there is
no else statement we store in it store
the output in list of two out two items
now let's go back over here
the final output will contain self dot
token and that is used to we are
explicitly declaring if the statement is
in if statement not because that makes
it easy to detect the statement in The
Interpreter so that's what the self
token does in the first value and cef.if
statements is just the output that we
saw previously the conditions actions
and else action
now let's go to The Interpreter
in The Interpreter we have
okay so yeah over here in The
Interpreter we check if the first value
is reserved we first of all check if the
instance of the trees list then we check
if the first value is reserved and then
we check if it's an if statement
so we're using the
so we're using this first item over here
we're checking if it's reserved we're
checking if it's an if statement in that
case we are gonna
iterate through each condition in the
conditions list
and we're going to also store the index
of our Loop
then we're going to interpret the
condition and if the evaluation turns
out to be to have a value of 1
then in that case we need to we're going
to use the corresponding index and match
the action using that corresponding
index and we're going to interpret that
action
finally if the length is 3 that means
that there is an else statement I'm
going to interpret that else statement
but and even if both of those conditions
fail that means even if there is no l
state if there's no else statement and
the if conditions fail
and the LF conditions fail in that case
I'm just going to break out and return
so that's pretty much it I noticed one
error I had made beforehand is that in
the compute unary method I've forgotten
to return the output in the form of an
integer float and I updated that as well
so finally I'm gonna go to Shell and I'm
going to run this we can have
expressions like if I is greater than 2
2 make a equal 3 and you see we get a
equal to 3 and this is my printing from
here so let me just delete this
evaluation print
so let's control C clear
I'm going to do if 5 is greater than 2
do make a equal to 3
.
3 we get a equal to 3 if 5 is less than
or
7 is greater than 3 do make a equal to
6.
we can we make equal to 6 if 5 is
greater than or equal to 5 do make a
equal to 9 a becomes nine if
let's see if
a
is equal to 9
and 7 is greater than 3
do make b equal to a plus 1
and B becomes 10. so that's the if
statement covered and with that we have
completed if statements variables and
expressions
so in this section of the course I
created the while loop and first of all
I modified the lecture and before we do
that we need to think about the grammar
Rule and this is how it looks like it's
similar to the if statement where you
have a while divide keyword followed by
an expression followed by do followed by
a statement so I just add a while to the
reserved list and that's it to the Alexa
now I moved the passer in the passer
apart from the if statement check I also
need to check if it's a while statement
and I need to return accordingly
I am returning a while statement over
here so self dot while statement so I
move from the while keyword and move to
the expression
and then over here I store the
expression as a condition
then if the value equals to if the next
value is equal to 2
in that case I'm going to move and then
I'm gonna store the action
and then I'm gonna return this list and
again for that special case when you're
using unary operations you kind of move
ahead
because you call Boolean expression
within the factor method and that's why
I need to add this additional check over
here
so that's it in the passer now let's
move on to The Interpreter
so The Interpreter remember we had the
check for if the value was an if now
let's check if the value is wild then
these are just some checks all right
there we go now we check if the value is
while in fact I don't even need this
action over here so then I store the
condition self dot interrupt three one
zero that is the condition that we
passed from the passer to The
Interpreter
then while the condition.value is one
that means while that condition is true
I'm gonna do the action and print out
the response
since after interpret the action then
again I'm going to update the condition
because if I don't do this the condition
won't get updated
and I'm going to update the condition
and then again we're going to go into
the while loop and check if the value is
one
so with that with those changes let's go
and run the shell so I'm going to click
on run and now let's do
make a equals zero
while a is less than 10. do make a
equals a plus 1 and if I run this we get
a equals 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and 10 and
finally we get none printed out so I
don't really want that so I'm gonna go
to the Shell and I'm gonna say if
result is not none
only then I'm going to print the result
else you're just gonna leave it empty
so let's do
make a equals 0
while
a is less than 10 do make a equal to a
plus one
and that gives our correct response over
here and as you can see it converts it
to floating Point numbers for some
reason and these are just some minute
details that are that are a bit buggy in
our code it's not 100 full proof it's
not as good as the modern programming
languages but the goal of this course
was to teach a few Concepts and create a
simple programming language which can
compute arithmetic operations and also
some additional functionality as well